all right there we go
okay good evening everyone and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
stratford-universe district council's
planning committee my name is peter
richards and i will be chairing this
evening's meeting
before we get into the main body of the
committee
and the agenda a few household keeping
items if i may
please note that the meeting is being
live streamed and recorded for public uh
for publication on the council's website
and through youtube
members you'll have been given uh the
council's etiquette for virtual meetings
in advance of this meeting however to
reiterate a few of the main points
please make sure that your devices are
plugged in
and charging or have already been fully
charged please can you mute any other
devices so that we don't get disturbed
during the meeting
if you could also please mute your
microphones when you're not speaking and
of course remember to unmute them
when you are called to speak
if you encounter any i.t problems
throughout the meeting
that causes you to drop out of the
virtual meeting please do make every
effort to get back in again
a phone number has been added to our
chat function so if you can't rejoin
please call that to get some assistance
if for any reason you can't get back in
again that you will have been deemed to
have left the meeting
at that point and the meeting will
continue provided it remains
correct i can also confirm that checks
have been made to ensure all members of
the committee
are in attendance and have confirmed in
the presence of our council's legal
officer that they can see and hear the
proceedings and have read
all of the relevant documentation we
have a number of
officers online with us at the moment
from committee services we have olivia
quinn
our planners are joe brook victoria
kempton stewart flaherty
louise coleman and our planning manager
is dale barker
and our legal officer is ross chambers
dale i believe you may have a statement
you want to make before we start
is dale there
it seems dale's having some i.t issues
so we will uh continue
sorry i'm with you um thank you yeah my
mind
i apologize good evening um my name is
dale barker my
role is to give members impartial advice
members are not bound by any advice that
officers may give
thank you marvelous thank you very much
um for members of the public
uh you will be given a 30 second warning
during your speech before it is
for your three minutes or five minutes
are up when you come to speak
please do press the star and six buttons
on your keypad that will unmute your
microphone and enable you
to be heard by the committee and by
members of the public
um could you also please refrain from
having
the live stream from youtube feed in the
background
it is slightly delayed and does tend to
cause some issues
um so please use your telephones rather
than the live stream
to be updated as to where we are in the
meeting and if you could turn off any
live streams that would be
very helpful okay let's move into
the main body of our agenda um if we
start with apologies for absence please
olivia
chad we've got apologies from
councillors curtis mills and henshaw
sarafin but counselor henshaw servant
will be speaking as ward member on item
four
marvelous thank you very much and in
disclosures of interest if you can
indicate please in the chat function
i can see a few i will very quickly
start so
uh i am the ward member for our final
application
which is uh number seven application
number twenty zero one
three four two ful cozy cop the green
snitfield i will be removing myself from
reaching that point to speak
um and i i will leave the committee in
the more than capable hands of
councillor bill fleming
um i believe i also know the applicant
on
uh item six twenty zero one nine three
four ful old vicarage road
um i played rugby with him many moons
ago
we haven't really seen or spoken to each
other for a good number of years
certainly
since i became a councillor so um i'm
entirely happy to remain
on the committee with an open mind for
that item
councillor parry thank you and good
evening chairman
i just wanted to advise that i'm the
county councillor
for two applications this evening uh the
one in barely and also the one in
snitterfield
items six and seven on the agenda
but as far as i'm concerned i'm i'm
i've not been involved in either
applications or in discussions
at the parish council meeting so i'm
quite happy to be
um debate and take part in the
proceedings on those two applications
lovely thank you very much cancer parry
and councillor edwin
thank you chair um i'm the neighbouring
ward member for
item number four which is the
application in studly and i will be
speaking on behalf of the applicant so
i'll be removing myself from the debate
at that point lovely thank you very much
cancer redden
uh there being no further declarations
of interest
we will move on to our first planning
application
uh which is application number twenty
zero two
zero eight four ful of the methodist
church uh methodist chapel
in radway um we have no
speakers registered uh to speak tonight
sorry no um there's no war member no
parish council which has
uh triggered this item to come to
committee it is
uh part of our procedures to therefore
vote
to delegate uh two officers i propose
that we do go to vote and delegate to
officers could i have a second to please
councillor parry
yeah i have councillor paris indicated
that she would like to second
uh in which case we shall go to a vote
um councillor richards
four thank you councillor fleming
cancer fleming for councillor kendall
councillor kendall for cancer adam
councillor had an abstain
that's the jennings pastor jennings four
and cancer paris councillor parry four
chair that's eight four and one
abstention
marvelous thank you very much olivia um
in that case the committee resolves to
delegate the decision
for application twenty zero two zero
eight four ful netherlands chapel in
broadway fabulous thank you members we
will move to our second item for the
evening which is application number
twenty zero
one four one f u l five green lane in
studly
could we confirm that we do have our
speakers in
hello yes chairman the speaker is in
marvelous um
who is our speaker that is in i just
want to check who it is
is that mr mike osborne also i counsel
my gospel
marvelous um class was one i think i
heard the live stream in the background
is
you're probably better served i've muted
it now
slight delay so um i've muted it
marvelous thank you and we'll call on
you when you when you're ready to speak
i'm going to mute you now
okay good um so our presenting officer
is louise coleman
louise are you there
for members of the public louise has
been experiencing some technical issues
this afternoon so we may have a second
to bring louise in
louise can you hear me i can't
can you hear me we can hear you loud and
clear now yes thank you very much
whenever you're ready are you able to
put the presentation up on your screen
or do we need someone else to share it
i hopefully can use it can everybody see
this
it's coming up slowly
okay okay um if
everyone can see i shall proceed um
the application site identified by the
black dot on the map
is located to the north of studly town
i do apologize there is a bit of a delay
on this
inside is i the application site
is identified by the site edged in red
and is located within the west midlands
green garden special landscape area
the piling is the county boundary with
redditch and a traveler site with a
three-year tempe permission lies to the
south of the site
with other residential dwellings located
to the north west
and east planning permission is
sought for the erection of a two-story
side extension
the extension will be more than double
the width of the dwelling and extend
backwards
by 3.5 meters beyond the two-story
element of the property the extension
proposes to reconfigure the existing two
up two down configuration
and provide a replacement bathroom a new
lounge and kitchen area and ground floor
with an additional two bedrooms and a
bathroom at first floor
this will result in a four bed property
sorry just waiting to go to the next
slide
oh sorry it's stuck
on this i think this is my internet
connection i do apologize
that's okay
hopefully it'll turn over
if it doesn't change do any of our other
planning officers have access to this
presentation
that could show it for us chair i can
show you the presentation
for you if necessary yeah um
dale would you mind doing that please i
think we're probably going to lose
connection with louise louise hopefully
we'll still be able to hear you speak
but if dale for now yeah puts the
presentation on his screen that would
probably be the best way
forward that's that's fine okay
i will i will uh stop sharing
and then dale can continue if you're
able to dale
yes thank you chair i'm um loading the
powerpoint now
it'll take probably a minute which will
feel like much longer
um it's got to drag a lot of information
down the down the internet
that's fine no problem
um
jake please confirm you can at least see
the powerpoint logo
um we can see the powerpoint logo slowly
loading itself
yeah good yes we're nearly there
okay
i think we're we were about to move to
slide four
yes i think we were it should be the
elevations
of the property okay we have the
elevations on our screen now so louise
if you want to carry on
okay okay i however can't see that but
i'll i'll go regardless that's fine um
dale you'll just have to verbally uh
tell me because i i can
only see your powerpoint um initial
screen
um i can't actually see the presentation
so you'll just
have to give me the verbal uh indication
so we're on elevation the extension
okay do you want to be informed the
extension is
uh elevation please that's where we are
carry on okay um the extension is
proposed to be subservient in height
to the existing dwelling with a front
bay window matching
uh similar in design to the existing
frontage
the extension would amount to
approximately 110 increase in volume
when compared to the original dwelling
this calculation takes into account the
removal of the single story
rear projection as a result uh
if you can go to the layout plan the
next slide along please
donate
the results thank you
as a result the extension so as a result
of the extension the existing vehicular
access to the property
of a green lane will be closed and of
new vehicle
access created off the register road
slip road two brick walls with
piers each spanning five meters in
length and two meters in the height
either side of new timber gates are also
proposed
the gates are proposed to be set back
from the frontage by 4.5 meters
and a new hard standing for parking
created
in their garden the heart dining area
doesn't require consent
if we can now go on to the photographs
please
are we on sorry set of photographs
yes okay um the first photograph on the
left hand side of the screen
is the original front elevation of the
property with the vehicular access
and open garden area shown the
second top right photograph is
the renovated frontage of the property
an
adjoining terrace the lower left
hand side photograph is the
rear elevation of the property with the
adjoining projection to be
proposed to be demolished that's the
single story element
um and the last photograph in the
in the slide is the side gable of the
property
looking in a westerly direction
if you go on to the next set of
photographs please
done and just let me know if we're on it
yes we're there
so thank you the
i think it's the left hand side is the
location of the new access with brick
walls and gates
and that's the existing eastern boundary
and the other slide is a view looking
east at the houses on the old falcon uh
pub site
in summary griffin
oh sorry the griffin uh pub site
um the proposal is inappropriate
development in the greenbelt
greenbelt designation is the highest
form of protection afforded in
planning law therefore unless members
consider that very special circumstances
exist
they should refuse this application the
very special circumstances provided
although it would enable the family to
live in the area
redevelop a derelict site and one of the
occupants has a medical condition
officers consider very
only very limited weight can be attached
to improving the dwelling because the
site is now occupied and renovation
works has been carried out
finally the applicant has provided
medical evidence of an occupant's needs
the needs are our potential future needs
for downstairs accommodation in the form
of a bedroom and bathroom
no evidence has been put forward to
suggest that the dwelling can't be
adapted and the plans
put forward identify a bedroom at ground
floor or justify
the the size of the first floor
accommodation in terms of the medical
needs of the occupants
as such officers consider the needs
could be met by
in-policy compliant man in a policy
compliant manner
and these personal circumstances
therefore don't justify
making an acceptance agreement belt
policy however
this will be a matter for members to
weigh and balance and come into their
decision
in conclusion it's considered that the
application
fails to record the green belt policy as
the extension would result in a
disproportionate addition to the
existing house
and the walls and gates are new
structures both of which are
inappropriate developments
where no very special circus have been
advanced the harm therefore to the
openness
of the green belt has not been
outweighed by the very special circs
there is one update to note in the
update sheet
and the recommendation is to refuse for
the
reason listed in the committee report
thank you chair
yeah thank you sure louise louise thank
you very much and thank you for your
patience with the
the i.t issues that we're having um we
will move straight to our first speaker
i think
uh who is councillor mike osborne uh
councillor osborne if you could press
star on six on your keypad that will
unmute you and we should be able to hear
you
star and six councilors one yeah it
looks like you're unmuted
if you could speak so we can hear you
now you've muted again star and sex
hello kitty we can hear you now fabulous
okay so council osman you have three
minutes and we will give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up
whenever you're ready please go ahead
okay
councillors officers officers have
offered what they consider to be a valid
reason for
refusal and if we were in a normal site
we probably would agree with them
however this site due to decisions taken
by this council
virtually makes it worthless
the house is small and not suitable for
a modern family
as such with the gypsies and travellers
site at the end of their garden
all that will happen is that this will
slowly
crumble away the applicant is prepared
to invest their time and money
into creating a family home in a
sustainable location
so they can have a family home without
the changes being proposed the property
is cramped
damp expensive to heat maintain and with
very limited on-site parking
and is insecure the proposal will create
what
will be a modest family home with
acceptable levels of parking
so that the vehicles are not parked on
the road outside the house
making it safer for all road users
the design accords with the street scene
and offers significant benefits
in energy efficiency reusing an almost
derelict site
and helping to enhance the gateway to
the village
there is on the there is other than the
officer's blinkered view on protecting
the green belt
something that was overlooked with the
adjacent site
nothing to object to with this
application
the parish council supported the
application and failed to see any
justification
for its refusal members of the committee
you have the ability
to overrule the officer's recommendation
and put some common sense back into
planning
we fail to see how one application
that is totally retrospective and
against every policy
that the stratfor district council can
be granted yet one less than 50 yards
away that is not
retrospective complies with all the
adoptive policies and creates a much
needed
family home and it can be opposed
if members are concerned about
protecting the openness of the green
belt
then we suggest that permitted
development rights
are removed on the rest of the site 30
seconds
this would ensure that this was uh not a
speculative
application and the applicant wanted if
he wanted to
expand it in the future he'd have to
resubmit an application
on behalf of the studly paris council on
common sense
i ask that you approve this application
thank you
thanks rosman thank you very much if you
could hang on the line while i seek
members questions members do you have
any questions for councillor osborne
please indicate in a chat if you do
i'll give it a couple of seconds to give
you a chance to play
it looks like there are no questions so
uh council osman thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
you're probably best served now to move
back to
the live stream thank you but thank you
for your time
okay okay we'll move to our next speaker
who
is councillor eden who is speaking on
behalf of the applicant
counselor eden are you there pretty sure
you are
thank you chair i am um
you've got three minutes 30 seconds and
you've got some slime
okay um dale if you could bring up those
slides that would be very helpful
thank you
um and you're ready to go please do
start as always you'll have a 30 second
warning and hang on for questions
afterwards
no problem thank you thank you mr
chairman and good evening committee
members
uh mr little and his wife have lived in
studly for many years
and mr little himself has lived in
studly his whole life and their two
children go to local studly schools
they've purchased this property to allow
their family to continue to live in the
village that they love
the officers reasons for refusal are
based on the percentage size of the
extension
and the possible harm to the green belt
we'd like to argue against those reasons
as
follows the original size of the
property is very small so any percentage
of reasonably sized development is
likely to appear large in proportion
in fact once extended the footprint of
the house will only cover around four
and a half percent of the entire plot
the site is surrounded on all sides by
development which now also includes the
recently granted
gypsy traveler site which was approved
in completely open greenbelt land
neighboring properties on the same
terrace have benefited from extensions
in the past such as number four whose
current
size is similar to these plans but it
has a much smaller overall garden area
in comparison some of which can be seen
in the bottom right hand side
only just though uh slide two please
dale
as you can see the development is
entirely enclosed within a garden with
high fencing so any visual impact on the
open spaces is absolutely minimal
as is any concluded harm to the openness
of the green belt
it is in fact an entirely enclosed
development
the house was purchased derelict and the
plan restoration and plant extension is
sympathetic to the original form of the
property this is entirely an enhancement
and improvement project bringing back an
unused house into service as a
home the property was purchased in a
derelict state along with all the
associated detritus
as it was really their only viable
option due to a lack of affordable
housing in the area
mr little is also capable and skilled to
do the work himself to lovingly restore
it
slide three please down size and scale
of the new entrance is only that which
is required
to satisfy highways requirements along
with a replacement and continuation of
fencing that is already in place
mr little has also indicated to offer
officers that the proposed brick pillars
could be made
out of wood rather than brick should
that be deemed more in keeping with the
fencing it's replacing
and finally a very special circumstance
as evidenced to officers mrs little is
suffering from a worsening medical
medical condition which will eventually
lead to the future need for a downstairs
bathroom and bedroom the office's report
makes reference to downstairs bedroom on
page
19 but doesn't take into account the
need for downstairs toilet facilities
which may be needed far in advance of
any conversion of downstairs rooms to
bedrooms
mr and mrs little would dearly enough to
carry out these plans for a family home
that will allow their family to enjoy
our village lifestyle things such as
being close to their friends and family
and being able to walk their children to
school for as long as possible
knowing they will all have a safe and
happy upbringing in the home they've
made their own in summary we mr mrs
little with the support of the ward
member myself as neighbouring ward
member in the parish council
would ask you to grant this application
and allow them to build their families
forever home
in the village thank you
fabulous thank you very much council
redden members do you have any questions
for councillor
please indicate in the chat if you do
let's give a couple seconds councillor
councillor jennings yes thank you
chairman
um sorry counselor no i presume that you
you know this
um you know the site the building
um it's been described as derelict
and i'm looking at the what it looks
like at the moment it doesn't
particularly look derelict so just
clarify on that for me
so it was purchased of the screen you
can see to the left that was the state
that the
building was in when it was purchased
and that they've now
begun developing and renovating
okay thank you
okay any other questions counselors
i think that's probably a no so council
edins thank you very much we will move
to our next speaker who is
councillor henshaw serafin oh
apologies councillor parry has come in
with a late question for you councillor
eden so councillor parry if you want to
ask your question now
thank you chair sorry having it issues
here as well
um obviously with the picture on the
right
can counselor edwin can you advise is
the property
habitable now
i have to say i don't know uh i'm not
sure whether
i'm not sure
yeah i i can't answer that question so i
don't know the answer i'm sorry
okay hey can we
we have another late entry for you as
well council adam um councillor adam
has a question thanks chairman sorry
about the lateness um
just in relation to the the size of the
family that
um obviously has bought the property um
what what is that and um well yeah sorry
what's the size of the family um
it's two adults and two children
okay thank you okay lovely that i
i think that's the final late entry
we're having for you councillor eden so
we will move on to
councillor henshaw seraphin thank you
very much casper councillor henry
serafin are you there
i am here good evening chair good
evening uh members
good evening and welcome um you know the
drill you've got five minutes
we'll give you 30 second warning and uh
as always there may be questions at the
end so whenever you're ready please go
ahead okay
thank you thank you i'm supporting this
application
for the main reasons to create a family
home for modern living
the family want to stay in the village
they grew up in
mr and mrs little and children reside in
rented property at the moment
their children do go to local schools
studly is a village of aging people
and we should be encouraging younger
people to stay within the village
this extension should be looked at for
its merit
that will improve the quality of the
public realm
and enhance the sense of place
reflecting the character and
distinctiveness
of the locality it would not have
any impact on the large size this corner
plot
of land the cottage had been
in disrepair for some years which was a
blight
on the area as you can see by the
photographs
the extension and all the works will be
self-built
which council should encourage this type
of development
as for spoiling the greenness the
openness of the green
belt i disagree for one reason
that this council gave permission to a
travellers site
to the rear of the property as shown
by the photographs in the green belt
there there are no objections only
support from local people
parish council and me as ward member
we all live in this area and have looked
at this application
and feel there is nothing wrong with it
they should have more support from
council
in this application so i asked the
committee
to grant this application for a young
family
to enjoy their future bring up their
young family
and for planning for this they've
planned for mrs
little's physical health problems which
will only get worse
in the future is that's the reason
they need the extra space the existing
cottage
has only two bedrooms which could not
accommodate them
this extension really is a necessity for
them
as committee you can grant this thank
you
thank you very much council hunter
seraphin members do we have any
questions for our counselor for our ward
member
i'm not seeing anyone diving for their
keyboards ah councillor adam
over to you thanks chairman um it was
just in relation
i think it's something that the parish
council raised but i was going to ask
the ward member um it was in relation to
other
potential properties in the uh in the
village
that may be able to accommodate a family
of this size obviously it's a family of
four
um which i appreciate a three or four
bedroom house might be more
suitable for other other such properties
uh the open market not that i know of
most people have to leave the village in
this circumstance
to go to redditch which is a cheaper
area to buy property but they don't want
to leave this area
okay and slight follow-up on that has
there been
um a housing need survey or anything
similar
being carried out by the parish council
there is a parish plan for housing which
hasn't gone through yet because um
most of it is on paris land and it will
have to go to a referendum within the
parish
okay thanks very much
okay and counselor fleming has a
question for you as well council fleming
oh hey uh yeah just just sort of um
looking at this these are the old needle
makers cottages along
at the bottom end of green lane aren't
they yes
now i'm gonna say this is a semi
statement but a question just the same
um i used to go to school with a lad who
lived in those houses
quite a year or two ago i have to say
and they seem really small in the 1960s
so so for a modern family especially one
with
a potential disability um i think is
it it would be very hard to sort of
squeeze in even with
the small single story extension they
really are very small houses
but uh so i mean are they gonna are they
planning on living in it as it is
without the extension or does it have to
be done first
no they can't live uh without the
extension
uh the existing cottage is the skeleton
inside
um and they wouldn't wouldn't
accommodate enough room
they have one girl one boy so
they wouldn't be able to accommodate in
in that cottage at all
okay thank you thank you council
jennings has a question for you as well
council jennings
thank you so just to get a bit of
clarification on this
so they've bought that they bought the
house they've
sort of partially renovated it the
halfway through and now they've decided
that they want to
put in for an extension well they put
putting for the extensions some
months way back before they even did the
front of that house
okay so okay i understand thank you
okay okay i'm
assuming we don't have any further
questions for our ward member given
there is nothing in the chat so
counselling seraphin thank you very much
for your time and contribution we will
move on now
thank you a question thank you
councillor we'll move now to
any questions and clarifications of our
offices um
i'll start if i may um i'm not sure if
this is something for louise or whether
it's more for our planning manager we've
heard about the egyptian traveler site
that was granted permission
uh nearby my understanding is
the egyptian traveler regime is somewhat
different from
the wider planning regime dale could you
just give us a little bit of a
breakdown of that and tell me if i'm
right or wrong
uh yesterday i'd confirm that absolutely
obviously
the regime for gypsy and traveler
planning
sits within the same legal framework as
all other planning decisions um but the
the national planning policy framework
is the
the guiding light for most decisions
sitting alongside that there's a special
document
purely preserved for gypsies called the
um planning policy for traveller sites
and that policy led us to the
recommendation that we made and
obviously the decision that the council
made
uh on the adjoining site because it sets
a completely different sets of rules
because
gypsies have a completely different set
of problems to
to to the general public i hope that
answers the question
that doesn't indeed yes thank you so in
a nutshell
uh we we we're not obviously not
considering the gypsy traveler site and
it has no bearing on the decision we're
making on this site
okay lovely thank you um we have a
question from councillor dixon as well
please council dixon
thank you chairman uh it is a question
to the uh
to louise as much as anything um louise
without reference to
volume calculations you mentioned that
the damage to the openness of the green
belt has not been justified by special
circumstances
can you explain the damage to the
openness of the greenbelt without
reference to volume calculations please
hello can you hear me we can
um sorry my
end is it's all very quite glitchy so
can i just uh summarize it did you ask
what's the what's the um impact of the
extension
without referring to volume calculations
in terms of harm to the green belt is
that what you were trying to say
so oh what what you said but i i i
missed some words out
essentially louise yes essentially the
openness to
the the harm to the openness of the
green belt is your reason
for recommending refusal and it is based
i think
on a volume calculation what i'm wanting
you to do is like
without reference to volume calculation
given that
there are properties close to where i
live which have had a hundred percent
cap ended up in volume increases and
been approved without even going to
committee
therefore it's the harm to the openness
of the green greenbelt i'm wanting you
to define
without reference to volume calculation
because that is only a tool to help
assess it
it is not a definitive way of assessing
[Music]
well um my response would be that i
would take you back to the
the core strategy policy um for
developments
within the green belt and thirty percent
in
some volume i'm afraid that volume is
instrumental because of the location of
the development it is in a green belt
and um we do have a policy cs10 which
just set out
um headlines for
ex extending um um dwellings
within um within these areas
and uh this would result
i i'm afraid to say in a 110 increase in
volume
um for this particular property because
it is
doubling the size of it um that in
itself when you refer back to the
greenbelt policy
um it's whether or not we would deem it
to be appropriate development
or inappropriate development
inappropriate development is
more small scale
and this obviously because of its size
is deemed to be inappropriate
development
and therefore you have to go down the
route of very special circumstances
and obviously we've already gone through
the
the three reasons the very the three
circumstances that the
applicant has put forward um but from an
officer's perspective
we don't perceive that those
circumstances outweigh the harm to the
green belt
the other obviously other applications
would have been assessed on their own
merits
and there may have been very special
circs that have come
forward in that particular instance
where
members or officers consider that
the scale of the development is
acceptable
thank you louise luis thank you very
much for that i was a very full and
uh and quality answer um we have another
question from councillor adam as well
please counselor adam
thank you is that actually touching on a
similar um
point to the one that counselor
dickson's raised um
in relation to openness of the green
belt
how can i it's essentially i'm trying to
define that
in relation to a site which is totally
enclosed
um by what it appears to be hedgerows
um or other developments so i'm trying
to work out how much openness would be
affected by a development that can't
actually be
seen from from other areas especially
though it doesn't appear to be
um other public rights away or anything
like that could you could you sort of
just elaborate on
on how much openness uh plays into that
that assessment
chairman maybe i can give a a better
insight into that because i have control
of the
presentation um very first of all can i
confirm that you can see the photographs
in the presentation
we can yes okay so the impact on
openness
is that this area of currently open
greenbelt will cease to be open
greenbelt because it'll have a building
on it
this area of currently open greenbelt
will cease to be open
and this area will cease to be open now
it might seem that's a very small impact
on openness
but your policies and the government's
policies
are very clear on this that any loss
of openness in the greenbelt is
something to be taken very seriously
as a as um louise said in her
presentation
the greenbelt has the highest level of
protection uh
of any any protection offered by the
planning system
and whilst you might say in this one yes
it's a very small amount of
of openness that we're losing
incrementally adding it all together
you you progressively detract from
the open and attractive quality of the
green belt
and that's what leads us to the
recommendation that we've come to
and again as louis said in in her
presentation
you are perfectly entitled to weigh the
very special circumstances
that the the applicant has outlined
against that loss of openness
but the loss of openness really must and
should be taken very seriously
even though as you say it appears to be
surrounded by other development
thank you chair yeah thank you very much
again for a
full and very detailed response it's
very helpful counselor adam i think
you've got a follow-up question if you
if you want to ask that now
yeah so if that's okay and thank you for
that answer was
um did cover my concerns um the other
thing i was going to ask about though is
i think it was number four
the other end of the terrace um it does
appear that it has been developed and
that was raised by one of the speakers
that it's to a similar
extent to what's being proposed here um
could
the the history of that has the history
of that been looked at is there any
precedent that might affect this
application
yes chairman we've checked the history
of that property and
either the extension was carried out
before 1972 when obviously the planning
policy and the planning regime was very
different
or it's been built unlawfully i don't
think it's been built unlawfully i think
it's
what would that make it 50 nearly 50
years old
and planning has changed somewhat over
the last 50 years
i can't possibly tell you uh what the
justification was for granting it then
um but um it is
ancient in planning terms thank you very
much
thank you dale thank you uh council adam
we do of course have to consider each
planning application on its individual
merits which is what we are doing here
counselor parry you have a question
thank you chair
um i appreciate we can't discuss um
medical conditions in a in a public
session
um but i would i would like
are the officers fully aware of the
extent of the medical conditions that
have been
um i highlighted by the applicant
um and i just wonder whether um
other members would find it helpful in
in deliberating about this in because
that is what the
that has been focused as exceptional
circumstances
if we were to go into a private session
just to have
a little bit more clarity
officers do you want to have
information thank you chair
um we do have information regarding the
um occupant's condition uh in terms of
her
medical uh records um
which yes if if you wished for me to
explain
any further we would need to go into a
closed session regarding that
council para are you asking for us to go
into uh a private session to discuss
that or are you happy to move forward
knowing that the officers have seen that
the evidence
well i just feel this this whole
application does center
on these exceptional special
circumstances
um and and personally i would feel
feel it would be really helpful to have
a little bit more clarity
but i don't know how my other colleagues
feel
i will seek other colleagues views at
this point does anyone have
a simple question members do you want to
move into a private session to
understand the medical uh background to
this
or are you happy that the officers have
received the medical evidence and it has
not changed their decision
in terms of very special circumstances
would anyone like to comment on that
i'm seeing no comments at all cancer
parry unless you specifically want
to hear the evidence um i'm content that
our officers have received it and have
made a decision
in full knowledge of that evidence uh i
i suggest we we move forward
uh councillor jennings you've suggested
you want to make a comment
yeah i'm not a medical expert and i
don't know whether
um even going into detail
behind um behind closed doors as it were
would
i would be able to make a valid judgment
on that
so i have no medical background so
i'm not sure i'm not sure how and it
could well be beneficial it may not be
i'm just throwing it out there
i i think given as i said before our
officers have received
full medical background and details and
evidence to support
the the suggested uh special
circumstances
um and that it has not changed their
decision um i think we can
uh move on without the need to go into a
private session
as you rightly say we're not medical
experts and it would be wrong of us to
make a medical
or a decision based on on medical
information i think
so um counselor adam you've got a
question you want to ask
please make it brief if you would oh
well um i'm thinking i agree
i just want to um clarify exactly the
information that the officers will have
received in terms of the medical
um situation whether that would have
been from
medical experts themselves or just from
the applicant
as it were
through youtube if you'd like me to
respond to that
yeah we have received uh medical records
from
1995 um and including a letter from
the um occupiers doctor outlining
outlining the condition um and also the
doctors outlining a future possible need
for space
so we have taken that into account
thanks very much
lovely thank you very much okay um there
being no further questions to our
officers let's move into the debate
who would like to start us off
don't all shout at once
i will go in that case if no one else is
going to um
so it is a tricky one um
whilst i do believe that people who have
dwellings properties within the
greenbelt should have the opportunity to
expand those um there is a limit to
uh to which one can do that and that is
enshrined within greenbelt policy and
greenbelt law
clearly our officers have made a
professional judgment based on the
evidence that's presented to them
that judgment is that the size and scale
of the extension
would be inappropriate in the green belt
and as a result would either
require a refusal or require very
special circumstances with which to move
towards a grant
i don't think the very special
circumstances have been set out
fully and properly that would enable us
to go against the officer's
recommendation
against uh greenbelt policy national
green belt policy as well as our own
as a result of that i propose that we do
refuse
in line with the officer's
recommendation and i will seek a second
councillor dixon has indicated that he
would like to speak council dixon
thank you chairman i am of the uh an
alternative view
uh i don't suppose that might surprise
you um essentially
i'm not i'm identifying any harm
to the openness of the greek filter um i
hear what the officers are saying but
equally well
i'm of the opinion very much
that there is no harm and no damage in
this
particular instance um the
local members indicated that the
property was a two-bedroomed and it was
a
an old cottage and small cottage i can
think quite simply that if you start
with a tiny cottage
and you double it in size you still end
up with a small cottage
um essentially i don't see the harm in
this one
thank you say council dixon understood
a very fair point councillor kendall you
have indicated you liked a second would
you like to speak to that
uh i don't really have anything
additional to say uh other than what
i completely agree with you council
richards it's unfortunate i feel for the
applicant
but i i think the scale of the
development is just too big
and that's why i'm happy to second you
marvelous thank you very much councillor
kendall um remember does anyone else
want to say anything at this point does
anyone else want to
come in councillor fleming has indicated
castleflaming
yeah i uh i tend to side with uh with
councillor dixon on this one because uh
um i'd like to say have been having been
in one of those cottages
a long time ago if you double the size
it's still not a very big house
and i have difficulty in seeing what the
harm would be
um even within greenbelt restrictions
uh to the locality or the people who
lived there
um let's say i know it was a brownfield
site but they built fire i wrote teresa
five houses
across the road from it when they
knocked the pub down um
so in all honesty um i would have an
alternative view to you
chairman
sorry i'm having trouble with my machine
unmuting um you're entitled to your
uh ulterior view to me um thank you for
expressing it now counselor adam you
you want to speak thank you um i
think i'm to side slightly with the
councillor dixon and council fleming on
this
um as well um just on the on the issues
that were raised that
that were raised in relation to the
impact on the green belt
i i appreciate there is an impact how
much that has and the uh the extent to
the harm caused by it i think is what
i'm putting into question um and
especially with
other development um in the area so
i'm stopping short of putting forward a
proposal um
to grant but those are my sort of
feelings um along with the other members
so far okay lovely thank you very much
council adam councillor parry
please thank you chair
um i've obviously looked at this
application really quite carefully
um i'm in two minds about this it i
think it is a very difficult one
and i think it could could go either way
but at the end of the day
the whole green belt issue is about harm
to the green belt and in view of the the
it's almost from a cumulative aspect
with all the other cottages
i really cannot see and whilst i
understand that the extension is
particularly large
um in addition to that there are some
special circumstances
so i'm still thinking about it but
more than likely to side with councillor
dixon and fleming at this moment in time
okay uh councillor jennings from final
counsellor to indicate to speak council
jennings when you're ready
yeah uh again it's one of these things
where
um logic
doesn't make logical sense but
um the rules are the rules
um i'm i am struggling to see the harm
but
i would have said that when you before
you buy a house
do your homework and you're seeing green
belt
you know it's in green belt you know you
can only extend a certain amount
um so i'm
i'm tending to go uh with
the proposal at the moment
my thoughts okay
thank you very much councillor jennings
councillor crump
a last-minute entry last one is century
a bit like the eurovision song contest i
think um
yeah just uh almost admit i tend to
favor
uh council of paris argument i thought
councillor jennings was slightly harsh
there with it with his comment
uh about by beware uh and the green belt
etc
um so i'm certainly um
i think it is about harm and how much
harm there is
uh and like i say it's in planning
balance
and if we were all uh in agreement on
all the different items
there would be no point having the
planning committee so therefore i
welcome this debate i think there's
there's been some good points put
forward by both sides
but um i would probably be in support of
councillor dixon rather than
you i'm afraid on this one mr chairman
thank you
that's absolutely fine councillor crump
as i say everyone's entitled to their
own opinion
um i would just stress that we've
already had a proposal
a proposal on a second uh that has been
seconded sorry to refuse
for the for the reasons outlined in the
committee report we haven't had a
proposal
and it certainly hasn't been seconded
for an ulterior view
we have to take the first one first so
while we're taking that vote given
what's been said i think we know which
way this could be going
i think you need to really think hard
about the reasons why you want to go
against the officer's recommendation
i think the point that i was trying to
make before was that um any harm in the
green belt
um is harm and therefore would be
inappropriate
unless there are special circumstances
that have been presented so please do
think about
the reasons why you think the harm that
has been identified
can be outweighed uh um
sorry counselor chambers ross our legal
officer has indicated that he would like
to make a very quick comment
uh ross yeah you've just said it really
chairman it's um
it's members need to consider obviously
um
that in order um to grant this
application
um very special circumstances need to be
demonstrated so
members need to have that in mind
demonstrate those thank you
thank you very much ross okay we have a
proposal we it has been seconded that
proposal is to refuse in line with the
officer's recommendation
i will start the voting councillor
richards four
thank you chair councillor fleming
council fleming against
councillor kendall councillor kendall
four
councillor adam councillor adam again
councillor cramp that's the crump
against
councillor dixon councillor dixon
against
councillor jennings councillor jennings
a harsh four and councillor parade
councillor parry against chair that's
three four
and five against
i'm having yes thank you uh olivia um i
i am having
a few minor technical issues with the
muting and unmuting of myself
okay so that uh proposal therefore fails
um we need someone to propose grant and
a reason for
councillor dixon has indicated he would
like to do that please go ahead council
dixon thanks german
apologies for the typing it doesn't seem
to be coming out quite as easily as uh
as i'm hitting the keys but uh
essentially my reasons for
proposing grant is that i do not
identify
any harm to the openness of the green
belt
essentially a small property doubled in
size
but even that does not actually harm the
openness of the green belt
in my opinion
that's my reason okay thank you um i can
see
um two members have indicated they would
like to second that being councillor
fleming council adam in that order
um before i call him to speak um
i'm concerned about that reason uh
because of what i said before
that any build form within the green
belt
is by its very nature inappropriate and
damages the openness of the green belt
we need a very clear and strong reason
as to why we should go against
that policy um i believe that to be very
special circumstances but i will refer
to our officers to tell me whether they
think that reasoning is sound
dale are you there
i'm here yesterday i was pausing to see
whether louise was going to respond
um yet my concern is
not that councillor dixon has concluded
that there'll be no harm to the openness
of the greenbelt from this development
it's all the other instances
where exactly that same argument will be
advanced
and it's the cumulative effect of that
argument
on the openness of the greenbelt that's
my concern that's that's what the
uh greenbelt policy is set up to prevent
and that's why we take things so
strictly
um so yes chair i absolutely share your
concern
i think in going down that line you will
be setting a very dangerous precedent
for many many many extensions in the
green belt which is strictly contrary to
your policy and to national policy
thank you thank that's exactly what i
was trying to say councillor dixon do
you want to come back
yes please i was just looking at the the
officer's report on page 17
where um the officer
indicates that on balance i am satisfied
that the proposal would not harm the
character and the local distinctiveness
of the host dwelling
the street scene and the wider local
area
and therefore when we actually look at
any application
in the greenbelt we should always be
considering the impact
on the openness of the green belt in its
location
and where it is fit where it fits if it
is
in the open countryside then indeed
impact along the openness can indeed be
dramatic
but where it is i think very close to
the border with redditch
which is not in the greenbelt um i
really do
have concerns that we are basically
saying that
uh irrespective of local circumstance
local situation local street scene if
it's based on
volume and it's a hundred percent we
must throw it out
unless there are very special
circumstances there are cases in my ward
which did not have special circumstances
it was just that the extension couldn't
be seen from the street
thank you councillor dixon um i would
stress that the
extract that you've just read from um
specifically refers to the design and
distinctiveness it is part of the
summary for that section
not the summary for the green belt um my
my belief mindsetting is this is an
issue with green belts not the design
and distinctiveness
so we have to be clear for the reasons
why we think we can go against
national and local policy on green belt
which clearly state
that any development in the green belt
is inappropriate
so i would like a more robust reason uh
to go
against the officer's recommendation
please while you think about that
um i have a lot of other people that
have indicated they want to speak so let
me go through them
um through each of our councils
individually so first of all
council fleming indicated he would like
to second council flaming is there
anything you'd like to add or speak to
on that second thing or can we move to
our next speaker
um there's nothing i have to add at the
moment but
now i think you can move to the next
speaker thank you very much thank you
very much council adam same question to
you
um well i was going to ask uh i mean
raise
essentially the point in this that i
think
very special circumstances have been
raised by the applicant
and i appreciate the reasoning behind
the officer to um
reduce the the weight that these have
based on effectively the layout of the
ground floor
but i think what this doesn't quite pick
up
in in a way that i'm totally satisfied
with is that
there is adaptability i know it mentions
that and the the the requirement for
those very certain very special
circumstances to be
required uh to be accommodated
is um effectively a future event um
i think that that does mean that those
very special circumstances
qualify to outweigh the
um impact to the green belt um
which i think goes hand in hand with the
actual impact being
um very low in my opinion um which seems
to be similar to councillor dixons if
you see what i mean
okay um i'm not sure if there was a
question wrapped up in that but
let me go through the speakers first
then we'll um i'll ask our planning
malaysia to come back and give his view
on what's been said
um councillor crump you've been
indicated next yeah thank you
mr chairman um obviously we've been
discussing this and
i feel that the community has given
their indication that they feel there
are special circumstances
to allow this by the amount of support
it's got
the ward member supports it the
neighboring ward member supports it
the parish council has spoken about it
spoken very eloquently about it
there's been 14 letters of support
against one letter of
objection so i think that the community
feels there are enough special
circumstances
to allow this small incursion into the
green belt
in their own part of the green belt not
any other parts of the green belt but in
that particular part of greenbelt ran
studly
so that's the way i would argue it and i
feel that
by saying by mentioning it was that
stood the community
was saying this they felt it acceptable
it wouldn't be set in the precedence for
the part to the green belt but
i might be wrong but hopefully somebody
will will think that was a reasonable
comment
thank you mr chairman uh thank you very
much councillor crump
um whilst i understand your sentiment
i'm not sure that that in itself
uh could be deemed to be a very special
very special circumstance
uh isolated to this dwelling and this
proposed extension but again
um when our planning manager comes back
to give his view on what's been said
um i'm sure he will be more than capable
of giving you a fuller answer than i
uh counselor parry you've indicated to
speak thank you chair
um i referred earlier in my questioning
in the
in the questions of the officers to the
medical evidence
and it has been confirmed that in fact
the medical evidence
provided has actually been provided by
medical professionals
um now at the end of the day um
you know a doctor isn't gonna or medical
professionals
aren't going to write in support of
someone with special circumstances
unless they felt it was important to do
so
it's not the applicants giving the
evidence but according to the officers
we have got
um letters from medical professionals
and therefore without wishing to divulge
what's in
in in those letters you know as i say
a doctor who is more professional
than planning um officers
has has actually written in support of
these exceptional circumstances and
therefore
i feel we have medical evidence to
support the special circumstances
because doctors do not write in support
of a condition
unless they feel it's important to do so
okay thank you councillor parry um
before we go to our planet manager i
would just say
whilst the doctor is more professional
in medical terms
that doesn't make them more professional
than planning officers our planning
officers are
more than professional in their
qualified field i just want to make sure
that that is very clear i'm sure that is
what you meant
um i also i i while we're talking about
that before um dale comes back to us
dale if you could just cover the um uh
whether or not there were letters of
support that were received from medical
professionals
or whether it was just a statement of
current medical uh condition
and if you could comment on everything
else that has been said as well
that would be very helpful
thank you chair on your first question
can i
put out a general question to louise is
she able to answer that question
now without doing any research if not
i'm going to have to read
the the my other screen before i answer
it
um because i i haven't done that that's
you know as you know
my job is to uh to manage the committee
not to know all the details of every
application
um louise i i can't answer
yes um i have uh a summary
of the the various different um
parts to the uh occupiers condition
and i believe that um some of the
evidence was just purely
medical records that have been um
submitted in order to obviously
demonstrate that the
evidence of the condition uh
um that there was a letter from um the
applicant's
doctor um outlining the potential
future need for um additional space
within and that that being
um in i guess you could say in support
of this application
they he was obviously aware that this
application had come
forward um and was wrong in response to
that
louise well while we've got you could i
just confirmed that was
um a letter from the doctor confirming a
future need or a current
need she has got current needs
but the current needs as officers
consider
um aren't so prohibitive that
she couldn't access they couldn't access
um
facilities upstairs for example in order
to
to access a bathroom for well actually
the bathrooms downstairs that they
present
um but there's bedroom accommodation
upstairs that can be accessed
louise i think i've found some useful
information which
i can share from the office's letter
from the doctor's letter
i don't think there are any confidential
issues in this
um okay please trust me for now um
i'm reading the the summary paragraph at
the end of the letter
uh which does not touch on her medical
conditions
it simply says the applicant is
extending her house
so that she has access to her bedroom
and ensuite downstairs
now members have seen the layout they've
seen that there isn't an ensuite
downstairs
there's a kitchen and there's a shower
room downstairs
and you need to go through public spaces
to get to all of the other rooms
and if you'd like me to show you the
layout again i can talk you through
why offices have concluded that actually
none of those rooms are suitable to be
used as a bedroom
in addition to that officers have no
problem
with meeting those medical needs
officers have no problem with providing
a downstairs ensuite bathroom
no problem with spent providing a
downstairs bedroom to meet the needs of
the applicant that's absolutely fine
it's the volume of the second floor that
tips this application
into refusal that's why we're where we
are
not the principle of meeting the
applicant's needs
but the the sheer size of this extension
um the only the other point you made
chairman
uh was to to address the the issue i
think of
um the very special circumstances that
the council trump bought up
and whether they were specific enough to
this case
to not set a precedent and i think i
would
i would leave that judgment to members
officers are clearly concerned that it
will set a precedent but that is a
matter of judgment that members
are entitled to make i hope that answers
the question
not very helpful thank you dale um ross
you uh you would like to make some
comments as well from a legal
perspective
just a general point on medical
conditions and personal circumstances
generally
the reason why officers advise that they
should be given very limited weight
is because they are personal to this
particular
applicant um you know you're not
granting a personal planning permission
these are permanent works
which will be here which will be here
for very long time long after this
particular applicant
is isn't here that's why um
in planning law um
the recommendation is to give very
limited weight to personal circumstances
generally
thank you very much ross um okay so um
we're slightly an impasse here we do
need to have a proposal
um uh we've already had a proposal to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation
which uh failed so i can only assume
that proposal to grant
is forthcoming but we do need to have
very robust
sound planning reasons as to why we're
going against our officer's
recommendation
who would like to make that proposal
the moment i'm seeing nothing in the
meeting chat if you could indicate if
you'd like to make the proposal
then please do
members this is somewhat embarrassing um
we do need someone to come forward with
something
like that or i'm going to make a
proposal that we refuse
again in line with officers
recommendation again and we revisit the
previous vote
but giving members have already had a
vote on that i want to seek your
reasons for a few for you for granting
first
[Music]
go on mr chairman i will i still
think that um there are special
circumstances
i didn't get a straight right no from
from dale
um or i'm happy to second
i've just seen cancer dixon's proposal
uh i'm happy to second uh
i'll take some comfort i didn't go
straight right no from dale in reply to
my question
um but i could see where he was uh
heading to with his uh
with his response um
going back to the legal officer's point
ross um
i know it touched on it as part of the
presentation
um i cancelled the handshakes everything
about attracting people and keeping
people
younger people in the village and in the
studly
and in the area as well and also people
living longer
as well than trying to stay in their own
homes so i
agree the fact that isn't uh the the
approval
um for medical conditions um
is limited a limited amount of time and
the person and somebody else will take
the house on
in the future but surely that's a that's
a house
that's been adapted for keeping
other people in in the area as well so
that
it's got a potential use once that
immunity has been created
that i mean it is the permanent is as
well so
potentially people can stay in staying
study rather than having to move
move elsewhere to assisted living or
sheltered accommodation so
that's just my thoughts on that one as
well again probably you're thinking i'm
talking out in the hat but
i thought i'd better say it anyway
okay um so i'm going to say it again
simply making a proposal to grant is not
sufficient
and i i'm not clear on the reasons why
we're going against
um our own policy council crime could
you please
uh reshape so i can understand your
reasons why we're going against your
your very special circumstances is what
i'm getting from this
as to why we're going against our own
policies in our national policy
yeah i i would say and say i'm of the
opinion
that i i'm still from what i've heard
that
the very special circumstances that have
come out
um this part of the presentation and the
and
on the debate i'm happy to um
i thought in this case it doesn't set a
precedent for the
um for the whole the green belt and
um also the fact that the there's strong
community support to this the fact that
they
they think that there are special
circumstances that out why
the the policies of the green belt um
with strong
local community support um so that
that's that would be my
argument on that one so ultimately the
very special circumstances are the
strong community support
um are they limited to that
well it's the stronger yeah the the
strong community support by
by people yeah and i'm happy to
with the um the medical
information provided as well to indicate
that
the circumstances are appropriate to to
build this
this property or have the property of
such a size
and i think the size was um the
particular concern so on
on with the information that's been
approved
and been provided you have identified
very special circumstances that consist
of the medical need
for the applicant and the
wider community support for this
development is that a fair summation
chairman if i may i i think councillor
crump has undersold himself there
because i think what he said earlier was
that
the adapted house would amount to an
asset to enable
people into the future to stay in
studly rather than having to move out
when they become old or infirm
and there is strong community support
for that asset
i think that's what council of crumb has
said but he struggled to communicate it
to you
thanks dan that was very beautifully put
dale thank you
okay i'm assuming from the thumbs up and
the thanks that council crump is happy
councillor dixon can you give me a nod
that you're happy with that and we'll be
seconding it
i'm happy happy to second that and
essentially
um i would comment that in the report
the officer obviously has to weigh up
the special circumstances and came to
the conclusion they weren't strong
enough we can obviously be out of a
different opinion
i do not disagree with that okay
in that case we do finally have a
proposal and it has been seconded
we'll go to a vote the proposal is to
grant for the reasons given
i will go first council richards against
sorry chad just quickly can i get um
ross's perspective and we've had
we have already had a proposal and a
seconder from councillor dixon
seconded by councillor fleming so that
is on the table
so before we hear this one that correct
i think that's what we're voting on now
isn't it we've no
we're not actually we were voting on
councillor trump's proposal with cancer
dixon seconding it
council dixon will you withdraw your
first proposal
yes joe yes mark thank you right thank
you olivia
for making sure we maintain process
properly chairman my turn now
conditions to be agreed with you
afterwards
i'm fine with that i'm seeing nods from
every other member so let's let's do
that as well
okay the vote is
to grant uh permission for
uh this development with for the reasons
that we have given
i will go first councillor richards
against
thank you councillor fleming
casa fleming four
councillor kendall councillor kendall
and abstain
councillor adam counselor adam four
councillor crump that's the crump for
councillor dixon councillor dixon four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
against
and councillor parade councillor parry
four chair that's five four two against
and one abstention
lovely thank you very much olivia um in
that case committee therefore resolves
to grant
application twenty zero one four one one
ful that's five green lane and studly
for the reasons given fabulous
do we have our speakers in for the next
item which is old stables
main road locksley
there's one speaker in chairman i can't
get hold of the other speaker i'm afraid
so who do we have in we have
um the applicant in mr morgan harold
okay given the parish council normally
speaks first shall we take a
one minute or two minute um break while
we try and
uh it's councillor glen jones while we
try and get councillor jones
in and if they are unable to join within
that two minutes then we will carry on
um anyway is that okay thank you
chairman thank you
members will return
okay members that is two minutes um
we have managed to get an engaged
tone to councillor jones so we are
hoping that um uh
castle jones is in fact diving in now so
we will press on
okay so our next item
is application twenty zero two three
three six
ful at his old stables main road
locksley
our presenting officer is victoria
kempton victoria over to you
evening thank you cher i'll just get the
presentation up now
hey can i just confirm that you can see
the slide okay
perfect okay i'll i'll make a start then
so the proposal is seeking to add a
two-story side extension to the old
stables in loxley
the application site is identified by
the black dot on the map
in further detail the red line outlines
the application site here
as indicated by the dash green lines
there are two public rights of way
beyond the south eastern boundary
in terms of the constraints the site
lies within the felden parkland special
landscape area
you can see that the old stables lies
within a range of former barns which
served a
home farm the joining barn conversion
shown here is called the bun
now the property was converted into a
two bedroom dwelling in the 90s
and as part of this conversion the old
stables has undergone a significant
amount of rebuilding works
including the addition of a roof turning
to the development
this slide shows how the two-story side
extension would relate to the host
property from the front
the extension would continue the linear
form and the ease would be approximately
one meter higher than the ease on the
main building
the modern glass link here would link
the extension to the main house
so in terms of the design details the
odd stables is finished in mainly stone
with roof tiles
but the extension would be finished in
reclaimed brick and slates
as seen at the barn it would also
incorporate different domestic
architectural features those used in the
old stables
you can see that the rear elevation
would include an engable which would
project beyond the rear wall of the old
stables by approximately one meter
interrupting this linear form there'd
also be alterations with the roof lights
on the main property
so this slide shows the existing and
proposed side elevation
but also in a section of the glass link
you can see that the extension would
largely obscure the original side
elevation of the barn
so the extension would create downstairs
living and family area
with the utility room at ground floor
and would also add an additional master
bedroom and ensuite at first floor
internal reconfiguration would divide
the bedroom into the main barn
and overall the proposal would create
two additional bedrooms
so this photo is taken from the
courtyard area looking in a southerly
direction
which illustrates illustrates the form
of the barns
the old stables is shown here and this
is the adjoining barn shown here in
brick
so this photo looks towards the
southeastern elevation which is the
elevation to be
attached to the extension and this shows
the stone wall which is to be demolished
you can see that the setting of the old
stables is characterized by an
arrangement of outbuildings which
agricultural in character and finally
this show this slide shows how the barn
contributes to the landscape when viewed
from the two public rights of ways
adjacent to the site given the scale and
design of the extension the proposal is
considered to result in harm to the
character of the barn
and consequently to the character of the
felden parkland special landscape area
it is recommended that this application
should be refused for the reasons set
out in the office's report
please refer to the update sheet for
comments made by the agent who is unable
to attend
this to to attend tonight thank you
well that's right thank you very much
for that members there is
um quite a substantial uh comment on the
update sheet so
if you haven't already please do read
that i think you all have
um we will move to our speakers now um
councillor jones has sadly not been able
to
join us and we're not quite sure why so
um what we do
have is a brief email from him
outlining his reasons uh to support um
i am going to read those to you now
clearly i can't answer questions
so i will read those and then we'll we
will move to our applicants
um so
we have lots of parish council continue
to support this application for the
extension to the existing building for
several reasons they are
it does not detract from the existing
building or setting
whilst the main residence was formerly a
barn it is not a structure with any
notable
architectural merits or features
applying policies to preserve
traditional barn structures is
inappropriate in this context
the decision is at odds with those taken
on nearby sites
the decision appears at odds with the
comments made at committee previously
and approval would enable a local family
to continue living in the village and
enable them to provide ongoing and much
needed intergenerational support for
elderly relatives living in adjacent
buildings that is the statement from
councillor jones
uh we will move now then to our
applicant
who is mr william morgan harold
mr morgan harold are you there you may
need to press start and six to unmute
your
phone
just to reiterate that is star six to
unmute
oh i've got a notification saying
that our applicant is leaving the
conversation
it looks like our applicant is not able
to speak or has left
the meeting so um councillor o'donnell
are you there
sure i am marvellous counselor donald
um given we have no other speakers
available to us uh we're straight to you
um
so you have five minutes you have you
will get a 30 second warning
so whenever you're ready please do begin
thank you chair and good evening
committee um i speak
in i've seen someone just coming into
the lobby actually i don't know if
that's
all right do you want me to wait and see
if it is
you carry on for the time being canceled
um i speak in support of this
application which meets a
number of our core strategy elements
it adheres to policies within the newly
adopted loxley ndp
is within the buab and most importantly
as you've heard is fully supported by
the parish council
many of you will recall that we first
came before you with this application at
the
start of lockdown one and you made
considered and useful recommendations
which mr morgan harold has listened to
and incorporated in his application the
palliative materials used would reflect
the local vernacular
in style there has been a rotation of
the roof through 90 degrees
to minimize impact and the eaves are
only slightly higher than the existing
ones to allow an
adult to stand up and that is actually
in a stooped fashion
the officer argues that in this case a
sympathetic conversion requires linear
roof slopes and built form with limited
openings to maintain an intrinsic
agricultural character of this barn
but i question this as there is very
little of the original agricultural
style evidence at all
the locals including the parish council
fully support this application
the applicant and architect have in
accordance with the nppf
front loaded and been in constant
communication with the parish council
local residents and the ward member you
will have noted how the old stables
is at the very end of the driveway and
the extension will not
impact on the view of the felden
parkland special landscape area
the new gable furthest from public view
will only be viewed through mature
hedgerows
it is a mismatch of buildings on home
farm and so the concern of the
difference in yves heights causing a
discordant feature
in the row of bonds is again one i would
question
this application supports cs1 as it
provides an increased supply of housing
to meet the needs of the present
and future generations and this meets
the needs the presence without
compromising the ability of future
generations to meet their own needs
in respect it respects cs5 as it
respects the local distinctiveness of
the surrounding area
and through respecting natural
environment it also respects cs6
through the sense to design and its
integration into existing build form it
meets requirements of cs9 on
distinctiveness and design
and also consideration is the loxley ndp
and respecting what the villagers
overwhelmingly voted for as their vision
of loxley
a theme running throughout the nbdp is
that the villagers housing stock
is now significantly skewed towards
larger homes
in contrast to the small size of most
households
this mismatch prevents younger families
finding suitably sized accommodations
such as our applicants
as they start a family and need to
extend to a three rather than a one bed
property
and due to the imbalance between larger
houses and three bed and less
loxley has a demographic structure that
is skewed to older age groups
and far fewer younger people relative to
the national average
and loxley needs younger families such
as the applicants
the ndp set goals which aim to ensure
sensitive development which protects and
enriches the landscape and built setting
and they ask that development addresses
wider community needs
provides for greater housing choice in
locations
and delivers greater intergenerational
equity
and these were felt to be the keys to
delivering locksley community vision
it also included a policy focused on
replacement dwellings
and this was to facilitate the renewal
of the existing housing stocks such as
this one does
with appropriate replacements but it
also clarified
the policy did not intend to overtly
restrict people's freedom of expression
or interest in design and layout so
committee you have within your gift
the ability to frame this with logical
common sense
and grant a modest extension to the old
stables
and in doing so you will be enabling a
family to stay within a village they
have lived in
for 30 years and have strong links with
it will ensure that the applicant's
elderly and widowed mother
will not need to relocate as her family
are literally
on hand and it will also insist in
encouraging
younger families to stay in loxley i
would ask therefore that you favorably
look
on this application thank you
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our ward member please indicate in
the chat
if you do counselor parry
hello good evening and good evening
councilman donald
hello um i just wonder whether you could
uh expand on how this particular
application
um accords with the loxley
neighborhood plan which i understand was
adopted
in july earlier this year
so council parry um from my
understanding it is that
as i said loxley we have we need younger
families
and the housing mix at the moment is
skewed towards the larger executive
homes
which the younger families simply cannot
afford so it out prices families from
staying in the village
so on that level this accords with that
also
um home farm if you've done a site visit
i don't know if anyone's managed to
google google earth is quite deceptive
on this one it really is a mismatch
up there and so it can actually only
improve
what's currently available and will also
support intergenerational living because
it's literally
steps away between the main house where
the applicant's mother lives and then
with the house that they currently live
in and are looking to extend
so it meets the intergenerational aspect
as well and also locksley were not
prescriptive
about style um so it
their their vision is that they want a
difference a mixture of age groups they
want a mixture of housing size
and we are woefully short of the three
bed houses
in loxley as i say it's all larger
executive homes that are getting granted
thank you councillor donald members do
we have any other questions for our ward
member
i'm going to take that as a no
councillor opinion
councilman forgive me um
thank you very much for your
contribution please do stay on i'm going
to observe uh
uh while you're while you're here um
okay we're gonna try
and get our applicant uh back on i can
see
um that he has joined us um
so uh could mr morgan harold please
unmute his phone
by pressing star and six
i see some success there could you hear
us
good evening we can hear you welcome
thank you very much for uh for getting
back in again after after whatever
technical [ __ ] forced you out
yeah no problem at all so just so you
know
you obviously have you will have noticed
we've heard now from uh from the ward
member
um uh i have read out a statement on
behalf of the
parish councils we have not been able to
get them in you are now our final
speaker
you have three minutes we'll give you a
30 second warning and if you can stay
online
um after you finish there may be some
questions from members
um other than that whenever you're ready
please feel free to begin
thank you very much i ask that this
planning proposal be approved that the
idea of my wife and i relocating
is deeply upsetting if our home can't
evolve then we need to relocate
meaning we'll be tearing up the close
intergenerational family have been
together and part of this community for
30 years
we bought this property nearly three
years ago with the vision of starting
and raising a family of our own
and when i last addressed the councils
on our planning proposal at our first
committee meeting four months ago
without the exciting news that my wife
and i are expecting our first child next
year
this proposal will turn our one bedroom
property into a modest three-bedroom
that will allow my wife and i
to raise our child and future children
safely with their love and support
from our close family members and for
them to experience the wonderful
upbringing that our home's location
and intergenerational normal support
provides as a family with tight social
bonds having to relocate will remove the
support we offer to our adult
elderly and vulnerable relatives my
mother-in-law
76 and widowed lives directly opposite
us
my wife's aunt 79 lives alone in
tittington and my wife's granddad who is
106
lives in wells born the ongoing pandemic
has proved support vital for both the
first lockdown and now the second
we are doing their shopping picking up
their pensions and medical prescriptions
on a weekly basis
and most importantly are their social
support during what is a challenging
and obviously the only time for many
thank you
thank you very much and congratulations
on your fabulous news
thank you members do we have
any questions for our applicants please
indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing very little activity in the
chat
i'll give it a couple more seconds
okay it looks like there are no
questions for you so uh mr morgenhald
thank you very much for your time if you
want to hang out the phone now continue
to watch
on the live stream that is probably the
best way to do things
but thank you again for your confusion
this evening thank you
okay um so we've had all our speakers
members so we will move to
um points of clarification from officers
um i'm going to
start by asking uh mr barker if he could
um
give us some idea of the housing need
that was alluded to by
our ward member um i don't have the
benefit of
an mdp in front of me could you confirm
that there is a shortage of
three bed houses or if if that's not the
case
yes thank you chair um firstly i don't
have any detailed numbers in front of me
but i think
it's important that members look at that
question
in the round in the balance
excuse me if if there is a need for
three bedroom houses
in the village then obviously it's it's
really important that that
need is met um but
in granting planning permission for this
what members will be doing
will be taking away an existing
two-bedroom house
to provide that three-bedroom house and
of course two-bedroom houses
are exactly the sort of starter homes
that young people need
to stay in a village so it's not in any
way clear
to me anyway that um by
granting permission for this it will
enable young people to stay in the
village
it will enable the particular applicants
to stay in the village
um but it won't more generally
provide for the needs of the village
that's the first point
and the second point i i do want to
bring you back to
the advice and guidance in your
supplementary planning
document on design um which is very
clear
it says that the barns and agricultural
buildings
um will not normally be extended once
the initial permission has been granted
yes sometimes in granting an initial
permission
extensions have to be allowed in order
to make them work and that's obviously
what happened in this case
but beyond that nothing more than small
out shots or lead to's
should be allowed because it degrades
progressively
from the agricultural character of
buildings um they're the two critical
points i wanted members to
to weigh in their decision making thank
you chair
lovely thank you very much for that
councillor parry has a question
councillor perry
thank you chairman i was just really
wanting further clarification
on the appeal uh decision um
that was was given on glebe stables if
dale could just give a little bit more
information
in respect of its weight that we should
be considering
chair as with last time can i defer here
to the case officer who i think knows
this better than i do
sure that's just better i i do
that's not a problem so okay so so
glaive stables was put forward by the
applicant
um i've got some plans in my in my
presentation which i'll bring up now for
you
so if you can see that now that's the
elevations of the approved scheme
so this was a single store extension
which was best described as a lean-to by
the
by the inspector the barn was previously
extended
and the extension was to the rear of the
bomb which was ex
was screened by existing buildings from
the conservation area
it did have views um from distant public
footpaths
but the the inspector decided that it
was um
the extension was reflective of the
identity of the barn
so as you can see it is of a as a
lean-to
design i'll just show you the floor plan
as well
which gives you a bit more of an
indication of it
this this was also determined before it
was determined in 2014
which was before the adoption of the
course strategy um and that was partly
why we've given it little weight
in the determination of this application
is there is there anything further that
you have on this case
council parry do you have a follow-up
i think you might be muted counselor
parry either we've lost you apologies
uh my laptop's not behaving that's
absolutely fine and very helpful thank
you
thank you thank you victoria um
counselor adam has a question for you as
well
thanks um i might be slightly confused
um just on what i've heard tonight uh in
terms of the number of bedrooms the
existing property has i think dale
suggested two and i
thought i heard one elsewhere uh also
would i be able to see the
um the floor plans of existing and
proposed again
that's not a problem i'll just bring
them up now
victoria as you bring them up will you
please show the original permission
for this conversion to a dwelling which
clearly shows the two bedrooms
exactly so i thought i'd start off with
showing what's existing
and present so obviously you've got the
kitchen studying lounge there
um and that's that's that that's that
ground floor
but first of all you've got the one
bedroom i'll then show you as
as dale's just alluded to the the
approved scheme so
so excuse the quality of that so i
apologize
um but this does show that there's a
bedroom two in the position of the study
which is currently being used and then
for further information this is the
first floor
accommodation which was approved which
was as existing
so at present it's been used as a
one-bedroom house although it was
approved
as part of the conversion as a
two-bedroom property
thank you that's right is you happy with
that response
no follow-up valley wild after thank you
okay members do we have any further
points of clarification
for our officers if not we will move
straight to the debate
a couple of seconds to type
no one's typing okay uh let's move to
debate
who would like to start counselor
jennings
sorry it was actually a question okay
i'm glad
um it was just i wanted to find out how
much liaison uh did the
applicant have with you on this because
obviously
if you've gone through this six months
ago i would have thought
that all of these things would have been
resolved
and it wouldn't have ended up here so
i'm
just to get a bit of clarification of
what sort of what's gone wrong
probably i'm better to answer that one
chair um there's only so much advice you
can
give to applicants sometimes they choose
to
go ahead and submit applications despite
our advice
in the hope presumably that members will
come to a different conclusion
thank you very much marvelous
um victoria could you bring up the
elevations again on the screen this is
for councillor dixon's benefit and while
you're doing that cancer parry has
indicated she would like to start off
in the debate so councillor parry over
to you
right sorry chair still struggling with
laptop etc
um i think i think the key principle
of this application and the officers
report
um obviously is focused on the design
of the barn and as a rural district we
have
an abundance of barn conversions
across our district so the key issue for
me
is is really about part g part g
of um the development requirements of
the spd
and it's really quite we we have to be
really specific about
it because we are a rural district with
so many bonds
we have to have a set policy
um on that but also um
our extensions guidelines means that
any extension has to be subservient to
the host
dwelling so on this occasion
um despite the very eloquent
presentation of support by council
o'donnell as much as i would like
to support this application i'm going to
have to go with the officer's
recommendation
and uh wish to propose refusal
thank you chair
cancer perry thank you very much for
that members do we have anyone
else that would like to speak or would
like to second that proposal
please indicate in the chat now if you
would like to make any further
comments in the debate i think
councillor jennings is typing
yep councillor jennings would you like
to speak to your second thing
yeah not much further to add uh i i very
much like to
i wish i could grant it but um
i can't i'm gonna i'd like to second
this
proposal to refuse okay i can see
council adam has uh has also typed
second as has councillor dixon
council dixon casper adam do either of
you want to speak to that or are you
happy for us to move to a vote
a shake of the head is fine
okay we will move straight to the vote
in that case um so
uh the recommendation uh sorry the
proposal has been seconded
is to refuse the application in line
with the officer's recommendation
i will uh go first councillor richards
four
councillor fleming cancer fleming four
councillor kendall kessler kendall four
councillor adam councillor adam four
councillor cramp cancer crumpfort
councillor dixon council dixon for
chancellor edin council reading
for chancellor jennings
council generating sport and councillor
parry
councilman parry for that's unanimous
chair
thank you very much olivia um in that
case committee resolves to grant
application twenty zero two
three three six f you uh sorry terrific
i do apologize to refuse
uh application twenty zero two three
three six ful in line with the officer's
recommendation victoria thank you very
much for your full and detailed
uh presentation and committee report
we will move on to our next application
if our speakers are in
could i have confirmation
i believe we have one of our speakers
already here we'll just give it a couple
of seconds while we try and draw in
our other speakers yes
there's just one and the others are
dialing in so there shouldn't be a few
moments
okay in that case i can hear pinging
coming in so in that case let's crack on
um and uh and we can have the uh the
officer's
presentation so um the next item is
application twenty zero
one nine three four f u l that's old
vicarage smithfield road
barely um our presenting officer is
stuart flaherty
stuart over to you i can see
a map in front of me now many thanks
german uh good evening everybody
um this proposal is seeking full plan
admission for the erection of a dwelling
uh and all of the associated works uh
this includes the demolition
of a existing shed and garage the
application site
is within the village of barely
indicated by the black dots on this plan
uh here we see a plan showing the
application sites its entirety
um here
accessed off ashlane and just off
sincefield road
the purple line here uh indicates the
extent of the conservation area
one can see the application site is
partly within the conservation area here
and partly outside of the conservation
area
the red building here is poachers
cottage the red indicates that this
property is grade two listed
the application site is also within the
arden special landscape area
uh this application site is within the
wider residential
curtilage of the host dwelling old
vicarage here
here we see the submitted proposed site
layout plan
um this building uh here
is outside of the application boundary
and is a residential annex
of the poachers cottage uh the entirety
of this
uh application site is uh washed over by
greenbelt
i now have a zoomed in image of this
same plan
um here we see um
the dotted purple line here which
indicates the extent of the
uh emerging buab built up area boundary
um again one can see that we are partly
inside of this boundary and
partly outside um
the entirety of the built form of the
proposed dwelling uh the front drive the
access the integral garage
is all within the bubb
and then there is approximately nine to
ten meters of rear garden proposed
that would be outside of that bob
here we see the proposed front and rear
elevations um this dwelling is to
complies
uh liars stone timber cladding
black aluminium framing um and natural
slate roofing
with a green sedum roof proposed as well
on here and behind the garage
to the rear here um one can see this
dwelling would appear to be
somewhat single story when viewed from
the front um
this is us stood on ashlane looking
uh at where the dwelling would be cited
this is going in part to the topography
of the site
um and partly through modest engineering
works that would
that would uh take place um as is
demonstrated more on this rear elevation
here to drop the house down but this is
very much uh a two-story dwelling
um just on the front elevation here i'll
just point you in the direction of there
is a dotted blue line you may have
noticed
uh that is the extent of the previously
proposed dwelling
uh within the lifetime of this
application the applicants have since
reduced
the size and bulk uh you can see this
dwelling in relation to the existing
annex here
where this dwelling uh sort of the ridge
here would be marginally lower than the
existing
annex here now similarly we see the side
elevations
um again this i think this better
reflects the sloping topography of the
site
here we now have some photos of the site
uh we are stood on ashlane
at the proposed point of vehicle access
uh we are looking westwards
um vehicle access has achieved through
this existing
access that exists um we can one can
also see the two buildings here and here
that are proposed to be demolished to
accommodate this dwelling
um here we are now stood on ashlane
looking northwards
uh up the slope um of the road
um this is the said annex um in
different ownership uh here we are now
stood at the point of access this time
looking
down the slope down the hill of ashlane
looking westwards positive and proactive
discussions have taken place between the
applicant and this district to reach
what is considered to be an acceptable
development on this site and presented
to members this evening
this proposal achieves a high standard
of design that provides a simple yet
polished material palette that yields a
modern design and delivers
a modest family dwelling in a
sustainable location
uh i would point members in the
direction of the update sheet
um chairman the recommendation is to
grant this application for the reasons
set up on pages 46 and 47 of your gender
packs
thank you stuart thank you very much
um okay we will move to our speakers if
they are there so i have the parish
council
first um i've got two names written down
councillor richard lepage and councillor
aslan
erin mess have i said that correctly i
hope so
yeah i have
yes fabulous is it just yourself uh
councillor
mess counselor and chair of barely
parish council last night
and i will speak for this application
okay lovely well you have three minutes
and we will give you a 30-second warning
um as soon as you're done if you want to
hang on the line there may be questions
from
our members but aside from that whenever
you're ready you're good to go
indeed the site is garden land in
ardhan's special landscape
area of the green belt as the officer
said partly in buab
and conservation area boundary
old vicarage frontage is to snitterfield
road
site assessments for ndp identified
potential limited infill for two homes
between the vicarage and rivendell with
frontage to snitterfield road and no
other limited infill potential
for the garden land limited infill was
defined as
completion of an otherwise substantially
built up frontage
by filling an arrow gap normally capable
of taking one
or more one or two dwellings only
there is no built up frontage in ashland
some 60 meters south from snitterfield
road
there is a garage with an attic
conversion
further 14 meters south from the garage
is
hollyhock cottage both a small scale
with mature trees and hedging borders
in between the proposed develop dwelling
therefore cannot be regarded as limited
infill
as it will not be filling a narrow gap
in a substantially built-up frontage
the proposal does not address the
established need for affordable housing
in barely
either it is inappropriate development
in the green belt as per section 13 of
mppf and policies of course strategy and
barely ndp
clearly ndp has passed the examination
stage in august it is no longer of
limited weight
as suggested in the officer's report
the development comprise compromises the
openness of the green belt
it severs the connection between the
local
wildlife sites to the south and the
local green spaces
ecological mitigation will not be able
to fully address the damage due to
loss of trees and other amenities
the proposal is an appropriate
development
in the green belt which would cause
substantial
harm to the openness of the green belt
there are no public benefits or
exceptional circumstances
for all the above reasons barely so
strongly objects to the proposed
development
i'm done marvelous councillor ermez
thank you very much for that um i will
seek questions now from our members
members could you indicate in the chat
if you have any questions for our
counselor
i'm seeing nothing at the moment
it looks like there are no questions so
councillor nms thank you once again for
your contribution tonight um if you want
to hang up your phone and continue to
watch the live stream that you're
probably best served doing into that
way but thank you again for your
contribution yeah man thank you
committee
thank you okay uh we will move now then
to
our um applicant and their agent
we have mr greg white and miss jane
cashmore
do we have you both here you may need to
press star and sixth one meet yourselves
uh mr white we we heard you uh briefly
there and then you cut out
are you are you still there yeah can you
hear me now
i can indeed uh welcome is it you just
yourself that will be speaking
um okay how are you going to split your
time are you are you happy to just crack
on one of you speak for the first same
minute minute and a half and then
whoever hasn't spoken to continue yeah
mr white will go first
and then i'll i'll carry on and we'll be
less than three minutes between us
okay we'll give you a 30 second warning
once the three minutes is approaching
that'll probably be directed more
towards yourself uh
jane than than mr white but whenever
you're ready
please do go ahead there should just be
one slide to put on the screen that's
okay
okay stuart would you mind bringing that
up on the screen for us please
on your screen
if you could bear with us please jane
and mr white
apologies chairman i was trying to um
make you aware that was the slide i
believe
um give me a second just to um it was on
screen
um
the slide is now up jane i can confirm
yeah thanks to it
okay whenever you're ready then
okay good evening committee my name is
greg white and i am the applicant
the proposed dwelling is to be a
self-build for my family and i to move
into
i have engaged the local architects
familiar with the district and locally
and appropriate experts including a
heritage expert
to to help create a family dwelling
which will enhance the local
area the committee report is
comprehensive and clear we'd like to
thank the planning officer
for his hard work on the application we
provided amendments during the
application
process and addressed some local concern
to reduce the overall scale
and the lab scale and landscape design
thank you
i just wanted to take the opportunity to
iterate some of the key points from the
report
we recognize that there has been local
objection but we do not agree that the
proposal
causes harm barely is a local service
village where policy allows for new
build open market dwellings within the
physical confines
the proposed dwelling would sit on an
existing garden land in a ribbon of
development
and is within the physical confines of
the village where new dwellings are
acceptable in principle
the npps paragraph 145e sets out
that certain the mppf sets out certain
exceptions to development in the
greenbelt
and one of those is limited infilling in
villages
the parish council have referred to a
definition of infill but that is not set
out
in the core strategy as a definition and
the officer report acknowledges this
the site does constitute limited infill
and is therefore acceptable in the green
belt
as your planning officer has set out in
the report
the design of the proposal has been
carefully considered and takes account
of site constraints including land level
changes
as you can see from the slide on the
screen from the front elevation the
dwelling appears single story and lower
in height than the adjacent building
the blue dotted line on this plan shows
the height reduction as part of the
amendment submitted
as the committee report recognises the
design is high
standard and contributes positively to
the local vernacular
the report sets out that the proposal
would also contribute positively to the
conservation area
no consultees have raised objection to
the development and the proposal is
acceptable in terms of highways impact
ecology impact on heritage neighbours
and other detailed matters
thank you for listening and we're happy
to take any questions
marvelous thank you very much both of
you members do we have any questions
for our applicant please indicate in the
chat
if you do
everyone's been very quiet tonight it's
unheard of with a group of counsellors
it looks like we have no questions so uh
to both you jane and to uh to greg thank
you very much for your time and
contribution this evening
again if you want to hang up your phones
and continue to watch on the online
stream you're probably best served to do
that
but thank you again thank you chairman
okay um let us move now then to our ward
member who is counselor ian shenton
councillor shenton are you there
good evening chairman good evening
welcome
thank you for your patience so you know
drill five minutes 30 second warning
whenever you're ready feel free to start
thank you chairman and very good evening
to all members and officers
it's rare that i ever appear at the
planning meeting as i rely heavily on
the applies and skill of the planning
team
but in this application i feel the
recommendation is flawed
in the papers i've laid out my
objections generally and they all carry
weight
the particular application if granted
would appear
to be set in a precedent and extending
generally accepted practice
with regards to the openness of the
green belt in that the argument for
allowing the application is based
on there being no generally accepted
definition of the word infill
i would argue quite the opposite the
oxford english dictionaries offers the
following
it's a construction of new buildings
between existing structures
therein lies the crux in this matter
it's generally accepted
that this means that if there are two
houses in the built-up area
and there is a sufficient gap between
them then this can be infilled with a
new property
many councils use the following
definition and even within our district
is
one has been supplied to parishes who
embark on creating a neighborhood
development plan
the definition is as follows limited
infill development is the completion of
an otherwise substantially built up
frontage
by the filling of a narrow gap capable
of taking one or two dwellings
only substantially built up frontages
are defined as an otherwise continuous
and largely
uninterrupted built frontage of several
dwellings
visible within the street scene in areas
washed over by the green belt
some may have substantially built up
frontages whereas others are loose knit
limited infill will not be acceptable in
low density areas
where gaps between dwellings form part
of the character
of the area and contribute to openness
limited infilling is also not acceptable
in isolated
or loosening groups of dwellings where
there is a break between the dwellings
and the continuous builds up frontage of
the village in order
to protect the openness of the green
belt the mppf states that one of the
essential characteristics of green belts
is there an
openness infilling should not therefore
compromise the openness of the green
belt
unless we adopt this approach we'd have
the prospect of a couple of hundred
houses being built in the four miles
between the southerly built up area
boundary of wooden way
and the southerly parish boundary of
room coast and barcelona on the a3400
looking even closer at the gaps between
the two houses on that lane
we see that the gap between them is
something like 100 meters considerably
more
than what one would deem to be an
infield plot
even by the report's own standards there
is a big distance
still rather more than an infield gap
turning to the nppf the mppf says that
inappropriate
development is by definition harmful to
the green belt and should not be
approved
except in very special circumstances
which in this application do not exist
the exceptions that section 145 g
state that it should have no greater
impact on the openness of the greenbelt
than the existing development or
not cause substantial harm to the
openness of the green belt
where the development would reuse
previously developed land
and contribute to meeting and identify
the affordable housing
need within the area quite clearly will
have an impact on the openness
and will be clearly visible from its
elevated position
in addition there is no suggestion or
proof that this is being built for
any affordable housing need the report
accepts that the property would be
partly an open countryside
it's accepted that it's within the green
belt it is accepted that it is partly
within the conservation area
and within the yard and special
landscape area
the emerging ndp has great weight as it
has gone past the inspector
not as suggested within the report has
been of limited weight
the ndp is also clear on what is
acceptable and what the village sees as
its vision
of the future in summarizing the
application should be refused due to the
clear definitions
on what infill is and isn't
definitions on openness the green belt
built up frontages limited infill and
with a clear and generally accepted
approach within the district
that the green belt offers the highest
level of protection
and any building within the green belt
is harmful
as highlighted earlier this evening in
the previous application
plus we have the additional issues of a
special landscape
area conservation area and
archaeologically medium sensitive
site it is for all the above reasons
that i am appearing before you tonight
and why i feel strongly about this and i
would therefore ask the committee to
refuse the application
thank you for listening to me
counselor thank you very much for that
and the point that you made and
i i know the chairman of the parish
council made as well
about the ndp we do have an update that
of that on our
um on our update sheet so we have been
informed already that it does hold
significant rate rather than limited
just i just wanted to clarify that with
you um members
do you have any questions for the wall
member
lots of shaking heads no okay council
champion thank you very much
thank you very much chair okay moving on
to
officers recommend sorry uh officers
clarification or points of clarification
members do you have any questions or
points for clarification that you would
like to put to the offices
councillor jennings thank you chairman
yes i just wanted to get a clarification
on
limited infill in planning terms
thank you uh councillor um
at the risk of stunning glib how long
how long have you got really in that
respect
there's a lot of case law um an awful
lot of case law
um some of which has actually been
provided by the applicant in their
submission
um i've referred to some case law in
your agenda packs
um on page
uh 30 sorry 41 of your gender packs i've
given
what has been termed to be a definition
of infill
um and i'll quote it verbatim this is in
your reports as i say
the small scale development of a plot of
land which fills a gap within an
otherwise
built up area now that's um quoting
uh case law that has been accepted now
there is no hard and fast definition of
infill
is the fact of the matter has been
touched upon by all parties has been
acknowledged in this report
um there is no hard and fast definition
of infill we have to consider each and
every application on its own merits
um we we've done so we've had a look at
this we've looked at the frontage
um uh this is uh obviously touched on
the
the the merits of the green belt as well
um
i can only echo both what it said in the
report and also what jane has said just
now mrs cashmore
um it's we've come to a view that this
is limited infill
um as per um nppf paragraph 145
um i know cancer shenzhen made a
reference to that as well
um specifically part e of the mppf of
that paragraph
um whereby we deem it to be limited
infill within the build of area of a
village
um and that has been our view
excellent thank you very very
comprehensive answer we might need those
four hundred houses going from water
north to the
okay thank you very much thanks council
jennings thank you stuart
um council dixon you've said you have a
request could you
yes please uh can stuart please uh
confirm where that built up every about
boundary is please
i was looking at the uh the the plan
before us with the old vicarage
uh to the north of the site and i'm just
wondering
how the line is drawn as it were between
those
properties on what i assume the main
road
the old vicarage and the proposed plot
as for the built-up area boundary
because
having a ward which is made up of uh
local service villages myself i.e three
of them
with lots of infill sites in them and
the built-up area boundary that plays
a very significant part in decision
making
um yes uh no problem counselor can you
see my
can you see my plan on the screen yes um
okay
so this is the dotted line helpfully
provided by the applicants i may add
um actually shows the extent of the
built-in very boundary so
where my cursor is running now um that
is the extent of the boundary so uh this
is obviously this the built form the
footprint of the dwelling is inside
the old vicarage is inside part of this
tennis court of the old vicarage is
inside
and then many of you may know this area
there's a run of houses here along
snitchfield road
which are all inside um the boundary
thank you very much stuart i was going
to say the old vicarage looks like a
development site to myself but uh
perhaps that's
for another time thank you i think that
probably is for another time um
counselor adam has a question
i think it's actually related to the uh
counselor dixon's question
um in terms of the built-up area
boundary
as it is now uh looking at what's
included within the core strategy as it
is we're talking about the
uh emerging built up area boundary under
the neighborhood development plan and
obviously the
sap as well um but
what has been so ratified so to speak
under our current
core strategy uh thank you councillor um
in terms of our core strategy um there
is a specific policy
uh as10 which would relate to um
residential development
in areas such as this um
in terms of the actual status you are
actually right it's very much in
in flux i would say at the minutes um
that's partly reflected by my update
provided
um the barely ndp is now
post-examination um and the bulb
boundary within that ndp now holds
significant weight um and with that
this dwelling uh proposed dwelling is
deemed to be
is obviously clearly inside and that
holds um
some significant weight in our
assessment i made a separate assessment
in your agenda packs that in addition to
that
um this dwelling was within what we deem
to be the village confines
um that's a separate assessment done as
well and we
we were satisfied uh that that falls
within the village confine
in a ribbon development along ashlane
and with that there are provisions
um where as both in your report and as
mrs cashmore touched on where there are
instances where residential development
in these such areas can be deemed to be
acceptable
under certain other provisions clearly
but
okay that's really useful thank you
thank you thank you
uh counselor evan please
thank you chair uh it's a question about
the ndp really and
it being post-examination um the parish
councillor referred to
the emerging ndp or the post-examination
ndp as part of his speech
and they'd identified areas of infill
i'm obviously this area wasn't one of
those areas
but was this area mentioned at all and
if it were should
we afford that any weight is kind of my
technical question
thank you uh councillor um
my honest answer um is that i can't give
you a definitive on that so i'm afraid
it may have been
um i can't give you an answer not
without scouring through uh the ndp
um to the best of my knowledge i can't
say with any authority whether that
actually was considered by the parish in
their deliberations in drawing us
together
in their work with stratford policy with
other independent bodies
i i can't speak to that i'm afraid
that's fair enough okay um
unless there aren't any other points of
clarification from our members which i'm
guessing there's not there's some
shaking heads and nothing in the chat
let's move on to
our debate who would like to start us
off
please indicate in the chat either that
i'll have to pick on someone
her counselor parry has indicated she
would like to speak counselor parry
thank you sorry thank you chairman um
and excellent presentations this this
evening from all parties
i think the key to me is when you look
at the mppf
um section 145
and how it describes the exceptions to
development in the green belt which
highlights the fact
limited in filling in villages i think
also
with the um the site is
has has been identified as being with
within the built-up
area boundary um and on those two bases
my concern that is this went to refusal
that it
it it it would would clearly go
to appeal because the um
of the planning the planning officers
have recommended grant
and therefore on that basis um
and and the arguments that have been put
forward
by the planning officer um whilst i
appreciate and understand the concerns
of billy parish council i can't find a
planning reason
to refuse this based on the rules
on mppf on the green belt um
and because of our own core strategy and
policies on buab
so on that basis um i'm coming forward
to propose grant
lovely thank you very much cancer parry
councillor dixon
uh thank you chairman i'm happy to
second that i'll simply comment that
on my own ward comprises three local
service villages
each of them has had infill and infill
has been created by a demolition of
properties
in order that the gap can be created
if that can happen in the green belt and
in local service villages
i can see barely taking a a property
here
so our second e proposal
lovely thank you very much councillor
jennings has said he'd like to second as
well
um given it's already been seconded do
you still want to speak or are you happy
for us to move to our next speaker
help us move on okay counselor kendall
no i think i'm happy to move on as well
i i support what's been said okay
uh in that case um let's move to a vote
we have a proposal it has been seconded
the proposal is to grant in line with
officers a recommendation
um i do have some reservations over the
definition of infill and whilst i'm
slightly uncomfortable
with its use here i can see why it would
have argued uh
in the direction it has been so i will
uh
go for cancer richard's four
thank you councillor fleming cancer
flaring for
councillor kendall councillor
councillor dixon councillor dixon 4
councillor
that's unanimous chair
forgive me my mute button uh for some
reason is not working properly this
evening
hopefully you can all hear me um okay so
uh committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty zero one nine three
four ful
in line with the officer's
recommendation
let's move now to our final uh
application of the evening and this is
cozy cop the green and sims smithfield i
have already announced that i
am speaking on this so i will step away
and hand the reins over
to the more than capable councillor bill
fleming council fleming it is over to
you
thank you very much chairman um right
item agenda seven application number
twenty stroke
o one three four two stroke f ul
um it's cozy cost
and uh first thing i'll do is invite the
planet officer louise coleman to present
the application please
thank you yeah
um right i i'm hoping that this
will be able to present via my computer
but can can people see the um
location plan yes
yeah yes okay yeah okay
my screen it's gone slightly pixelated
but um
i will i will try to start the
presentation
um the application site is identified by
the
black dot and the map is located within
the village of snitterfield
can people see the next slide
no i'm still looking at the map
yeah i think it's just not working
correctly
um yes it's just freezing so if dale
will just step
in and i'll present us previously
if that's all right
so will someone please tell me is that
working
we have the map again yep good excellent
so let's see if we can move on to the
stock just yet dale
just i
i will talk you can just uh pull up the
plans and just tell me
which one you're on so this is before
you start just before you start louise
just before you start
will everybody please confirm they can
see the redline plan
i can see the black dot plan no just
okay louise had then
i've moved it on to the red line plan
yes you've got it now
there we have it yeah yep okay excellent
right
we're cooking with gas louise please
carry on
okay um i'm doing this blind i can't see
anything
so you'll just have to tell me when
you're on the next
slide and i'll just do it out of memory
um
it is identified by the sight edged in
red and is located in within the west
midlands greenberg
arden special landscape area and
snittyfield conservation area
residential properties located to the
north west and east of the property
with agricultural land to the south if
we can go to the next slide
please that's the proposed layout plan
i think it is um are we on that
we're on it yes okay
plan if thank you planning permission is
sought to demolish the existing
conservatory to the rear of the property
and replace it with a single-story
extension spanning the width of the rear
elevation
other alternates include a new front
door a canopy roof
small bin store and canopy roof over the
side door and all the windows are
supposed to be replaced with new timber
effect you beef
um the existing office building in the
garden
is proposed to remain if dale could
point that out
and it is proposed to remove a small
wendy house and shed
but these are unable to be included
within any volume calculations as
they're more than five meters from the
property
uh and you'll see a photo off of the
wendy house shortly
if we can now move on to the ele uh
actually it's the floor plans i think it
is
yes correct posed existing and proposed
floor okay thank you
uh the proposals seek to reconfigure the
internal floor space of the property
changing the room identified as a hall
into an office
convert the garage space into a living
room and utility
and create a kitchen diner space to the
rear
so if you could just now move on to the
existing
and proposed first floor plans i'm just
merely
showing these because it's just internal
alterations
with respect to that and uh then also
just if you're able then to just pop put
the slide of the proposed elevational
plans as well
just merely just showing that um
planning commission has previously been
granted for the erection of a two-story
extension
and a rear conservatory which have
amounted to an increase
85 percent increase in the volume of the
property
the proposed extension would increase
this further to 99
so now if you could just show the
photographs
so the first photograph
this is the front elevation of the
property where the entrance would be
created
um that's the new entrance i should say
and canopy um the second slide
photograph if you can put that
up is the existing front entrance which
would be replaced with a new window
um if you can move on to the third
photograph
is the rear elevation showing the
conservatory
proposed to be demolished in the rear
elevation of the property
um if you can move to the fourth
photograph the rear garden showing the
existing home office building
and the wendy house that the applicants
are
removing and lastly the location of the
new bin store which is in front of the
brick wall which hopefully you can see
in a photo
in conclusion offices consider that the
application fails to accord with
greenbelt policy as the extension would
result in a disproportionate addition to
the existing house with a cumulative
volume increase of 99
and is therefore inappropriate
development
the very special circumstances put
forward by the applicant
is their need for an additional home
office due to the kovic crisis
and also cite that the development is
acceptable as it's not visible
would create a better home and would
replace a leaking conservatory
and therefore and improve their thermal
efficiency
however in office's opinion these are
not very special circumstances
the harm therefore to the open so the
green milk has not been outweighed by
the very special circs
there is two updates into report
which one of which revises the
cumulative volume
calculations slightly and also revises
the wording of the reason for a refusal
which members need to note
the recommendation is to refuse for the
reason listed in the update sheet
thank you care
my mute button isn't working
particularly well either um
right thank you very much for that
louise um right item two we'll look at
that there are three there are three
speakers registered
to speak on this item and uh the first
one we have to bring forward
is jonathan kelsey snitterfield paris
council
mr kelsey councillor kelsey you have
three minutes
uh you'll be given a 30-second warning
when your time is about to finish
thank you uh canadian councillors
so the increase the applicants are
applying for is only eight square meters
and this would reduce from 31.4 square
meters on consultation with both the
planning officer
and the parish council this is a minimum
level to enable the applicants to create
two independent working spaces
so that both of them can operate their
business from home whilst maintaining
their
space for their children and family life
this in itself has created their own
very special circumstances
which they'll be able to outline further
in their presentation
the parish council has considered these
special effects excuse me
excuse me can i just stop you there are
you jonathan kelsey
i am all right okay fine thank you sorry
for interrupting carry on
that's right the parish council has
considered these special circumstances
and together with the development being
at the back of the property and
therefore not impacting on the village
scene
and being supported by both of their
nearest neighbors it has enabled the
parish council to support this
particular application
in addition when we reference page seven
of our ntp
it states the following the overwhelming
desire of the community
as evidenced through the consultations
that have informed this plan
is to preserve this thriving active
village
and its keen sense of community spirit
organic development should be sported
but carefully controlled
allowing the village to develop evolve
and not stagnate
the parish council has come to this
decision by considering and balancing
the policy set out in his mvp
by you supporting this family to
reconfigure their home but
limiting it to a very small increase it
gives them the ability to work from home
and achieve a work-life balance
but at the same time controls the
organic development of the village
thanks
thank you very much mr kelsey
do any of our members have any questions
mr kelsey please
ah cancer jennings
has a question do you want to carry on
matt please
sorry i think our counselor parries
before me
ah sorry it's just left him okay
we'll go to councillor parry please
sorry um
councillor fellaini my question was was
for the one before which was dealt with
it's not on medication okay farm will
revert to
uh to counselor jennings then thank you
um do you in in
normal circumstances do you work from
home or do you work from an office
um i'm not the applicant i'm the parish
council
oh sorry my apologies but the applicants
are coming on
on shortly i believe yeah i should
certainly ask them that question then
thank you okay
okay thank you very much councillor
jennings
do we have any more questions for the
paris councillor
no nothing coming up in the chat so
we'll say yeah thank you very much mr
kelsey
and uh you can uh follow the rest of the
uh
the proceedings from the uh from the
website
or from the live stream thank you
all right next speaker is mrs kathy
kimberly
who is a resident i'm assuming a near
neighbor of the the property
are you there mrs kimberly
hello uh can you hear me
yes we can now yep thank you very much
thank you chair
um i actually uh object to the
application
the development proposed taking into
account the
the earlier extensions made to this
property
means that the cumulative increase in
the size of the dwelling since the green
belt was established
in 1975 will be 95
uh that may have been subject to
recalculation
but this is disproportionately larger
amounting to
inappropriate development in the green
belt the snitterfield neighborhood plan
was adopted in 2018 and policy be3
applies
limiting extensions to 30 of the volume
as the original building
my concern is that in order to support
the application
reference has been made to another
earlier application for an extension
at blossom cottage also in the green
that was granted on appeal amounting to
a cumulative total increase in the size
of the property of 40
and this has been described as setting a
precedent
but i disagree with this the
neighborhood plan
was adopted in 2018
and is the most up-to-date policy in
respect of the green belt
the appeal for blossom cottage took
place in 2015
so a similar appeal today would take the
neighborhood plan
into account and it is a very clear
policy in the neighborhood plan
not a guideline that extensions shall
not normally exceed
30 this means that very special
circumstances would have to be
demonstrated
that outweigh the harm by definition to
the green belt
i'm very sympathetic to the fact that
covid 19
restrictions have affected many people
in how they're having to undertake their
work
and more working from home is taking
place putting pressure on the use of
space
i do not however believe this amounts to
very special circumstances that outweigh
the harm to the green belt through
a permanent development
i believe the application should in fact
be
refused under the present circumstances
thank you for listening thank you
thank you very much mrs kimberly thank
you
in plenty of time right do
any members have any questions
i don't see any questions in the chat um
in that case mrs kimberly you're free to
leave the
leaves a meeting and follow the
procedure on
on the live stream or on youtube thank
you very much
thank you very much thank you thank you
the next speaker
is the applicant or applicants as
as a couple it's sally and charlie
curzon who are the applicants
you have three minutes you'll get a
warning with 30 seconds to go
uh how do you propose to split the time
you get it one year or you're going to
share this
time yeah sure sally person here i
should do the art you do the whole time
okay that's no problem at all right
you've got three minutes you'll get like
say you'll get a 30 second warning
and uh so you can proceed now then
emily thank you very much good evening
councillors thank you for your time
and as you've already heard we received
an objection to our original plans from
from our parish council based on two
areas one was that the house had
historically been extended by 85 percent
and also was that we didn't have the the
very special circumstances needed to
justify a further increase so following
that objection we went through a process
of consulting with
architects planning officer award
counsellor
and came back with a changed um and and
much smaller um scheme so we changed the
net increase from 31.4 square meters to
eight square meters
so this is the bare minimum that we can
do to achieve what we need to achieve
as a family and we are using part of our
garage to do that has been has been
explained which was a suggestion from
from the parish council
the extension has no impact on the
openness of the green belt and only a
slight impact on one
neighbour simon chapel who you see has
supported the application
the point i really want to explain is
the very special circumstances so
as you will see we already have a home
office space but what we're trying to do
is create an additional one
the reason we need to do this is because
of the nature of the business that we
run
so we're both self-employed consultants
trainers and coaches
and so we make our living designing and
delivering training sessions and
workshops to organizations all over the
uk
and indeed the world over the past six
months we've had to fundamentally change
the business
and re-skill ourselves to deliver
everything that we do online to earn our
livings
as you can imagine it's impossible to
deliver that kind of a session
unless you have a completely
sound-proofed space
in which to be able to do that so we
have one space set up for that for which
we're very fortunate that we don't have
another
so over the last eight months whilst the
garden office has allowed one of us to
work
the other he has either had to turn down
the works or ask my dad who also lives
on the green to vacate his house so we
could use space there
this is obviously unsustainable what's
crucial in this though is that although
covid is the accelerant for this
happening to our business this isn't a
passing phase so we work with over 20
organizations
and the majority have already changed
how they run their learning and
development
running these sessions for their staff
online makes complete sense for them
it's efficient
effective far cheaper and saves a
fortune on travel costs
so we have clients who have already
moved out of their office permanently
some announcing publicly that their
staff will never return to previous ways
of working
so although the pandemic was the start
of this shift for us and hopefully
obviously that will pass for all of us
the way we earn our livings has
permanently changed and this is why we
need to make space
for this second soundproof workspace
within the house
what the plans allow us to do
specifically is to convert the front
part of the house
into an office for me to be able to work
in while charlie works in the office
in the garden and in order to do that we
have to move the staircase
that then creates the extension and in
order to retain the current living
spaces we have as a family so we're not
actually
making that space any bigger we're just
by making the office space we need to
extend that space at the back of the
house
so what we really hope tonight is that a
combination of making a smaller
extension and explaining these things
and a little bit more detail for you
makes you feel that you'll be able to
support the plans thanks very much i'm
happy to take any questions
okay thank you thank you for that does
anybody have any questions
looking down the chat oh hang on
uh counselor jenny do you have a
question
it's my previous question um it was uh
did you previously work in an office and
uh
i'm not i'm guessing from your your
comments that
um when when the pandemic is over and
we have the new norm um do you intend to
just work from home or will you go back
to an office environment
you know so our official um registered
business office is here but we were both
traveling so charlie a lot
internationally and me within the uk to
deliver our workshops and training
sessions so although we would have
the odd day at home we were very much
both out and about delivering sessions
um and and what we will do we will
continue to be based at home
and as i said the big difference is
particularly for our international
businesses that even now they're saying
you know
their full intention is to keep doing
their learning and development online
because they've had so many benefits
from doing it from cost saving
perspective so
we see that this is a permanent change
for us um even though
we imagine some travel will return but
it will be minimal compared to what we
used to do
and of course what's key is that we both
deliver these sessions at the same time
so it's if if we don't have this then
one of us has to turn down work and
therefore we lose half of our
income because one person can't deliver
the session unless my dad's house is
available but as i say that's kind of
unsustainable
long term thank you very much
okay thank you anybody else have any
other questions
nothing's happening in chat so from that
perspective
mr curzon thank you very much for your
presentation very
succinct and it was full of information
um you can now uh leave the leave the
meeting or you can follow it on
on the live stream thank you very much
thank you very much thank you everybody
thank you
okay right now we have
uh ward member our former chairman
mr repeat counselor peter richards
council plumbing thank you very much um
i understand i have five minutes with a
30 second warning hopefully i won't take
all that time
okay so members as you know
um the purpose of the greenbelt policy
is to prevent urban sprawl
and maintain the openness of the
greenbelt
the location of this site sits at the
very center of smithsfield village and
is surrounded on all sides by other
properties
the green where the application site
sits is tightly packed and any minor
extensions to the building in this
location would have little to no impact
on the openness of the green belt
and most certainly would not be
considered or could not be considered as
urban sprawl
indeed a series of minor extensions to
properties along the green have been
permitted under similar circumstances
in 2017 under delegated authority vine
cot
vine cottage directly opposite the
application site
was granted a two-story extension the
case officer concluded
in their report that the proposal would
not
have an impact on the openness of the
green belt
in coming to this view consideration has
been given to the fact that the
application site is located in a part of
a village
where the existing built form comprises
of a haphazard collection of properties
constructed in close proximity already
amounting to a substantial development
within the green belt
which impacts on its openness blossom
cottage a few doors up the road was
granted a small cell extension extension
at appeal in 2015.
the inspector's report concluded that
the extension was modest and
although it would have uh although it
would have introduced a volume above 30
of the volume of the original dwelling
its sighting at the rear would not have
harmed the openness of the green belt
this application is seeking a very minor
increase in floor area and volume
and volume to the rear of the property a
net increase of just eight
square meters on the existing building
to my mind and given both our own
officers comments
and those of a planning inspector i
conclude that this small-scale
extension would not have any significant
impact on the openness of the greenbelt
policy cs10 of our core strategy
supports small-scale extensions in the
greenbelt
as does the snitchfield neighborhood
development plan specifically
the ndp in its explanatory notes to
policy be3 which is referred to by our
resident
resident objector earlier on states that
um extensions should not normally exceed
30
of the volume of the original building
but proposals exceeding 30
must demonstrate very special
circumstances so
if you are of the mind that development
would have an impact on the openness of
the greenbelt
which i can test this can be overcome by
the very special circumstances that have
been presented
in this case the applicants both operate
a corporate training business
and as a result of the covered pandemic
they have been forced to work from home
in its current form the dwelling simply
does not have the required space to
enable this to be done
effectively and professionally this
circumstance is not
a short-term circumstance either nor is
it personal to the owners
the world has changed dramatically this
year with a move to home working
becoming widespread
and at times compulsory looking to the
future the shift to homeworking will
continue to grow and we must be in a
position to support
those that are required to continue to
work from home whether compulsory or
otherwise
by not doing so we would be actively
preventing a viable business
to continue to operate in our district
smithfield ndp policy econ 2 also
supports new employment opportunities
whilst this application is not
specifically seeking a new business
premises or venture the circumstances
presented are to enable the continued
operation of a viable business in
weighing up the pros and cons of the
application i consider policy econ 2
to be supportive given the supportive
policies
and the history of other extensions in
this location the fact that very special
circumstances have been presented
and with support from neighbours the
parish council and
myself as a ward member i see no
material playing reason to refuse the
application and would encourage you to
grant
for the reasons i have sucked out thank
you very much
thank you very much councillor richards
thank you
does anybody have any questions for the
ward member
no it seems very quiet out there like
you said earlier
thank you very much guys laurie i think
you can step down now that's it
thank you thank you
so what we'll do now is we'll go to
uh clarification
from the offices
if any any questions are right hang on
we've got a couple queuing up now okay
we'll go to
to uh councillor dixon first please
thank you chairman um does the
snitterfield ndp
where it is referenced to extensions and
buildings not
normally to exceed 30 does that conflict
with our own core strategy
if i can answer that chair um it's
it it's it's more prescriptive than our
core strategy because it actually states
a figure of 30 um
i think the word the specific wording is
in the
uh committee report it says uh
extensions to building shall not
normally exceed 30
of the volume of the building as it
existed in the time when the green belt
was established in 1975
the wording of the core strategy um in
the actual
policy itself doesn't specify 30 however
it is
used as a general rule of thumb when
determining applications
it's interesting to hear you say that it
uses the general rule of thumb
thank you very much it's in the
explanatory
um to the policy
i think
thank you thank you councillor dixon
uh councillor adams has a question
thank you uh chairman a slightly
speculative question
um and i suspect i know the answer is
there any precedent
for um previous extensions to be
considered
as part of the original building
um appreciate that the the time and date
which they may have been extended uh
maybe sensitive to that
there there have there's been a quite
substantial extension at the two-story
extension that was allowed in 1999
that was the initial one um which
equated to about 69 percent of
the volume increase to the original
property
so that was quite a substantial um
increase and then um in 2004
um the rear extension
which was an additional 16 volume
increase
was permitted at committee
by members and so this this would be a
further
increase over an additional 14 on top of
that
so coming to the 99 percent overall so
it
cumulative total would be 99 percent
okay that's fine thank you very much
chairman i don't know whether you can
see that but i've put
uh policy be3 of the neighborhood plan
on
the screen i'm hoping you can see it now
we haven't got that yet
ah right okay let's have another go at
that then um i
thought it might be helpful to clarify
um
to to answer councillor um adam's
question
right let me have another go
got another question from uh councillor
jennings if we go with that while you're
trying to sort your technology out
there we go oh you got it okay no
problem
so that explains why we are using 1975
as the datum because the policy
tells us that that's what we should do
and the point made earlier by councillor
richards
is there
normally not exceed 30 percent must
demonstrate very special circumstances
if you're into if you wish to
i hope that helps that's really useful
to see the text thank you
okay so so my my
question would be um this this extension
does is the percentage growth
of the original cottage before the x-ray
extensions
or does it because let's say you're
already talking about a 99
increase in an extension so the new
extension is a very small part of that
but how big is it compared to the
original the original cottage
but that that that is the point is um
with the permission in 2019 sorry the
permission in 2009
sorry 1999 um allowed
and a 69 increase over the original
volume
and then with the succession of the 2004
permission
that allowed it to it is currently 85
percent
um there's an 85 volume increase
that has been allowed from the original
dwelling
and whilst relatively small increase
for this additional um extension and
it's like reconfiguration
that's going to be going forward it
overall
it amounts to 99 cumulative
chairman i think it's very easy to get
confused by
quoting numbers um you're absolutely
right in what you say
it's a very small increase and i think
that that's the critical thing to focus
on it's a very small increase
but it's an increase it's an increase
over and above an extension that already
way exceeds what
would currently be allowed and that's
why the recommendation is for refusal
okay thank you for your guidance um
councillor jennings was coming back from
the question when i cut him off sorry
that's all right it was just they
committed developments
uh don't play a part here at all um
because it's eight square meters
did you say again that is correct
okay thank you okay thank you
um and if i was gonna ask if there any
further questions for the officers but
uh councillor dixon's come in with a
proposal
so he's gonna jump the gun a bit before
i even got to the
to the debate part of the thing so if
the question is finished we'll move to
debate then
and uh there's council addictions come
in
i'd like to hear from him first
thank you chairman i was just looking at
uh
paragraph 419 of the course strategy
the council previously applied a 30
maximum threshold relating to the scale
of a house extension
and replacement dwellings however it is
considered
that a specific maximum figure is in
many senses
arbitrary and a more appropriate means
of maintaining the openness is to
consider proposals
on a case-by-case basis from the
starting point
that maintaining openness in preventing
urban sprawl
is of the utmost importance i actually
go along with the ward member on this
one
i don't think there is an impact upon
the openness of the greenbelt with this
minor
extension and therefore i would
propose that we actually grant
permission and not
follow the officer's recommendation
okay thank you for that counselor dixon
i've got a cure people want to second
that we've got councillor parry
kendall eden um
and uh i know we've got ross chambers
we'd like to comment
i'll bring you in and then i'll come
back to the seconders
okay ross go on thanks jeff um just to
say members that this is a case where
you will need to um you'll need
you'll need to demonstrate very special
circumstances it's one of those cases
and so you would need to put that into
your proposal counselor dixon
okay so i'll go back to second is now
speak
uh counselor parry thank you chair
um well i was actually going to come way
in with what i feel is
special circumstances we are currently
operating
in exceptionally challenging times and
as a district
we are our main focus is to drive
economic recovery and business
and here we have a situation where we've
got
an existing business that is threatened
because of covid19 they have already
identified
the special circumstances as covid19 but
i think the special circumstances
also need to reflect the
the economic situation and and really
emphasize
that we're operating in un uncharted
territory with kovid
uh 19 um whilst there are promises of a
vaccine
on the horizon um there's no
there's no confirmation and there's
doesn't
it hasn't been the vaccines haven't been
certified yet
also you know it is widely reported and
i concur with the applicants
that the whole way of working is
changing
and much many more people are going to
have to work from home
in terms of the openness of the and the
impact on the green belt
um i don't believe there is any
the the harm that it would cause would
be insignificant
but it is the exceptional circumstances
in the current situation that we find
ourselves with kovid 19 and
as a district our main focus is on
driving the economic
um the economy forward so i believe that
that
is a strong enough case to support
grant on this application and i have
pleasure in seconding
the proposal thank you very much
um danny kendall was next so
do you have anything you'd like to say
danny yeah that thanks uh
chairman completely agree with what
council dixon and councillor parry have
said
god willing the pandemic will be over
soon but it it's changed our society
we won't go back to the way we were uh
so i completely agree with what
councillor paris
said this i think this constitutes our
special
uh special circumstances i won't have
anything else
thank you very much uh next move to neil
eden
thank you chair i think councillor parry
has summed it up quite nicely
um and i see councillor dixon has
commented as well on a point that i was
going to add which
uh of richard's race which was econ 2
was supportive
i think we can absolutely put that in
there as far as i'm concerned
so i'm happy to third or however far
down i am
okay no problem um i had a note in the
chat
from uh uh planning manager
mr barker saying that uh the core
strategy is superseded by the ndp which
supports their business in this
particular respect
um so go to next one go to is uh
councillor jennings
thank you chairman well i think i'm
gonna be the odd one out um
i'm struggling to actually see the
special circumstances i mean i think
every
everyone in in the district is
struggling with space and having
due to the pandemic but does that mean
that everyone can have an extension or
extend their house or put on another
other part of their building simply
because they're struggling with time
not really um and this house has been
extended a number of times
and okay it's a it's another little
extension
but you've got to draw the line
somewhere
and it's gone way over and i appreciate
that the 65
back in 1999 um
they they sort of got away with one i
think they sort of got away with another
one
um and i'm sort of you've got to draw
the line somewhere so
it looks if i'm going to be the old man
out but uh okay
that's my thoughts on it okay got a
comment from
councillor dixon saying about econ 2 has
been referenced by the ward member
um councillor crump's coming with a
question
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah i
would quite liken this to
the one that we um granted earlier on
in the agenda that i proposed
again i think there are special
circumstances on this one
again it's got supported award members
got support of the paris council
um and certainly there's two things
again
we could liken to the previous one one
um
we're creating an asset that can be used
to encourage people to work at home in
the future
and secondly we've not mentioned the
climate emergency
um which we fully supported we're trying
to encourage people to travel less
to pollute the environment to stay
idling in traffic with their engine
running
all sorts of pollutants and parts coming
out of their
their uh exhaust so i'm more than fiverr
trying to encourage people to work
home to their carbon footprint and also
be creating an asset
that again it could encourage younger
people
working parents to to stay in the
community so
whether those points are relevant as
well
again i'll be led by the officer um or
the planning manager so i'll just put my
two penis first and
now i'll shut up and uh that everybody
else about that
okay okay thank you thank you very much
councillor crump um i think we've come
to the end of all the questions
and we actually have a proposal on the
table
um and i think we should move forward on
that now
so uh can we have a vote please on the
proposal
to grant
yeah sure before you go to that um
conditions to be agreed with yourself or
with councillor richards with yourself
um i would say from an experienced point
of view i'd say councillor richards
is not acceptable if i may i'm not sure
i'm allowed to give you not allowed
okay what can i can i nominate
councillor kendall who's far more
experienced than me to make those
decisions
i'm not sure that's the case but i'm
happy to do it if you like
okay thank you okay thank you
right okay so we'll we'll go to the vote
then olivia sorry for cutting you off
there oh no that's fine
um so councillor fleming uh
this is proposed to grant isn't it four
four councillor kendall
yes council candle for councillor adam
kelsey adam four councillor cramp
that's the crump for councillor dixon
councillor dixon four councillor edin
against redding four councillor jennings
councillor jennings against and
councillor parry
councillor parry four chair seven four
and
one against and on the basis of that
uh almost uh unanimous majority
um that means that uh
we've given permission to grant and
that's the the decision of the committee
and there's no urgent business charge
there is no urgent business
do i have to hand back to councillor
richards to handle that or can i just do
that
i think we're right as there's none to
do
yeah okay fine so there's no urgent
business
and uh we can declare the meeting closed
that
all crikey just in time nine o'clock
2100 hours